Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Wolfgang quietscht. So, wir sehen Wolfgangs Frisur das erste Mal bei uns in real life. Wie viel Aufmerksamkeit wollen wir heute drauf legen? Naja, eins rastet aus.
Die Menschen sind begeistert. Ich bin es auch vor allem, dass ich die Kappe nicht mehr tragen muss.
Ja, sehr gut.
Erleichtert mir das Leben. Normalerweise beginnen wir immer mit einer Frage. Du hattest heute gar keine Auflage. Oder möchtest du doch was los?
Ich habe eine Frage, denn Wolfgang hatte gerade eine These. Niemand hier ist aus Frankfurt. So, wer ist aus Frankfurt? Drei Leute?
Nein. Es sind doch ein paar mehr, aber es ist erstaunlich. Ich habe eben mit Menschen gesprochen aus Leipzig, Bielefeld, Weimar, München, Berlin.
Bielefeld?
Ja, da wird es mit Luhmann heute schwer, deutlich in der Minderheit.
Wieso? Das wird immer gegen Widerstände durchgesetzt.
Ja, wir werden sehen. Dann spiel doch mal den Jingle ab.
Warte, eine Frage hatte ich dann doch noch. Wir hatten selten so viele, teilt es nochmal, ich kann doch nicht kommen, was auch immer, es stehen ja keine Gründe dabei. Wer von euch ist denn hier und hat sein Ticket erst diese Woche jetzt durch diesen Tausch-Service?
Ja, doch verankert sind.
Ist das Corona-Welle oder was? Was haben denn die Leute so gesagt, die ihr Ticket nicht?
Urlaub.
Urlaub, na gut. Dann lassen wir sie in den Urlaub fahren.
Ist es uns lieber als Corona?
Mustafa, machst du uns Licht ein bisschen dunkler? Wir sehen unser Publikum nicht.
Ja, so ist es sehr viel angenehmer.
Wer von euch hat dieses Intro das erste Mal in seinem Leben in einfacher Geschwindigkeit gehört?
Ja, gar nicht so viele. Ich sage es ja, Menschen sind nicht alle wie du.
Podcast bitte schneller.
Muss man sich immer wieder klarmachen, dass man nicht allein auf der Welt ist. Wir sprechen heute über sehr verschiedene Dinge und sehr viel auch übers Fernsehen. Und da gibt es ja erstmal eine Wiederkehr eines altbekannten Gesichts. Und vielleicht kannst du uns diesen Clip einmal spielen, wer da zurückgekehrt ist.
Vor zehn Jahren, da gab es Leute, die waren fünf Jahre alt, die sind jetzt 15. Hier ist quasi eine ganze Generation ohne gute Unterhaltung groß geworden. Und aus diesem Grund habe ich mir entschlossen, dass auch meine Verpflichtung gegenüber unserem Land wieder etwas zu machen. Und es geht nächste Woche, nächste Woche geht es los. Nächste Woche Mittwoch, nicht wie in den Zeitungen stand, um 20.15 Uhr, sondern um 20.10 Uhr. Denn das ist mein Geburtstag, kann ich mir besser merken. Komme ich nicht so oft zu spät, 20.10 Uhr. Aber nicht im Fernsehen, sondern nur auf RTL plus.
Ja, auf RTL plus. Da würde mich jetzt interessieren, wer hat RTL plus und ich. Du meldet, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Was machst du da? Sommerhaus der Stars gucken oder?
First Dates gucken.
First Dates, okay. Aber sonst sind es sehr wenige. Ein paar melden sich, vielleicht trauen sich auch manche nicht. Es ist jedenfalls so, dass RTL heute keine konkreten Zahlen veröffentlicht hat. Aber seitdem jetzt zum ersten Mal diese Show gelaufen ist, gab es wohl noch nie so viele Neu-Abonnenten bei RTL plus. Also Stefan Raab ist da das Zugpferd. Eigentlich geht man jetzt in die Richtung, in die Spotify die ganze Zeit gegangen ist. Also Spotify hat ja sehr teure Leute engagiert, Boehmer, Mahnen und Lobrecht, damit Leute ein Abo abschließen. Jetzt ist das ausgereizt und deswegen kann man die wieder auf allen Plattformen hören. Jetzt versucht man, über Werbung noch mehr Geld reinzubekommen. Und RTL nimmt jetzt Stefan Raab unter Exklusivvertrag, lockt ihn dann ProSieben ab und jetzt ist er das Zugpferd.
Er ist unser Joe Rogan.
Ja, das glaube ich jetzt eher nicht, denn Reden war ja auch nie so sein Talent und Fragen stellen auch nicht. Es war ja doch eher, dass so ein bisschen Stand-up ablesen und dann Musik machen. Ich glaube, dass er das an sich auch am besten konnte, wenn gleich dieses neue Lied, Power of the Mowl, nicht davon zeugt, dass er sich musikalisch weiterentwickelt hat. Es ist eher eine Regression. Da sind ja auch Chiago und Sido dabei. Aber ich habe den Verdacht, dass jetzt wirklich die 90er-Jahre mit einer solchen vollen Wucht zurückkommen, dass man es kaum aushalten kann. Oasis, okay, ist noch Geschmackssache. Stefan Raab, na ja. Und dann noch Friedrich Merz. Es ist mir ein bisschen viel.
Mhm, mir auch. Hat es jemand gesehen?
Du hast aber dir die neue Sendung angesehen.
Ja, wir saßen heute im Büro.
Ich nicht.
Und haben das gesehen. Ich war ein bisschen erstaunt, denn Thomas Gottschalk kam ja auch aus so einer Versenkung zurück und hatte ja einen Sprachfehler. Und darüber wurde ja auch wirklich diskutiert. Also, dass er schon anders klingt. Ich finde das bei Stefan Raab auch, ehrlich gesagt. Ich war ganz überrascht, dass er wirklich sehr komisch klingt. Ihr habt es auch schon gesehen.
Ja, da ist irgendetwas mit den Zähnen, würde ich sagen. Da sind vielleicht die Dritten ein bisschen locker. Man weiß es nicht.
Ansonsten ja topfit, aber irgendwas ist.
Jedenfalls sieht man doch eigentlich, dass gar nichts so Neues versucht wird, indem man jetzt so eine Mischung ausschlagt, den Raab und TV total macht und man ja auch sein Comeback eigentlich nur noch mal das aufführt, was man schon mal gemacht hat. Man lässt sich noch mal von Regina Hallmich verprügeln. Das ist ja auch gleich schon so ein Armutszeugnis zu Beginn. Und was ich jetzt hörte, ich habe die Sendung nicht geguckt, aber habe mir einige Kritiken durchgelesen, war es ja so, dass die Referenzen seiner Witze Jürgen Milski, Florian Silbereisen und Peter Maffay waren. Also damit kann man jetzt 19-Jährige auch nicht so sehr locken.
Doch, ich glaube schon. Also das Publikum, was er damals hatte, ist ja heute in seiner Altersklasse das am schnellsten Wachsende.
Ja, das stimmt.
60 plus. So, und die haben ja Kinder. Und Fernsehen ist ja immer noch so ein, das Gerät hängt an der Wand und Leute betreten zufällig den Raum und bleiben dann mithängen. Und da wird, glaube ich, ein Publikums, wie nennt man das, so ein Publikums-Flow möglich sein, der nicht möglich ist, wenn Kinder TikTok gucken, weil dann die Eltern nicht stehenbleiben. Ich habe in irgendeinem Podcast dieser Vergleich, du kennst ja auch die ganzen Influencer, Pamela Reif. Reif, ja. Die hat ja nun wirklich Millionen und Millionen Follower. Aber wenn du sie bei Stefan Raab in der Sendung als Witze-Referenz nehmen würdest, müsstest du es, glaube ich, dem Publikum erklären, wer das ist.
Ja, weil das RTL-Publikum ja auch alt ist. Also wir reden jetzt viel über das ZDF-Publikum, aber das RTL-Publikum ist nicht jung. Das konnte man sehr gut erfahren von Dieter Bohlen, als er da mal rausgeflogen war und dann ja bei TikTok so aktiv war. Sagt er jetzt, erreiche ich endlich mal die jungen Leute. Das geht ja über RTL nicht. Das war seine Aussage. Dann gibt es jemand, der war nie weg, der ist immer noch da. Und der mischt sich auch eigentlich nicht in die Politik ein. Aber er hat sich gedacht, jetzt, wo die Krise so groß ist, da muss er sich auch mal nicht nur mit Liedern zu Wort melden.
Ich habe mich politisch noch nie geäußert, weil ich Sänger bin und kein Politiker. Aber es macht mir große Sorgen, was hier in unserem Land passiert. Es kann nicht sein, dass man in Deutschland Angst haben muss, dass man irgendwo abgestochen wird. Wir wollen keine Messerstecher haben. Wir wollen uns in unserem Land sicher fühlen. Deutschland braucht Politiker, die sich um Deutschland kümmern, die sich um Deutschland bemühen. Und da setze ich natürlich auf Friedrich Merz und Söder. Deutschland braucht einen Trump, der für sein Volk da ist. Ich war gerade in Amerika und habe mit vielen Leuten gesprochen, die alle Trump wählen. So einen Mann brauchen wir hier in Deutschland, um die Menschen auch Vertrauen zu haben. Er ist laut und erpoltert. Das war Franz Josef Strauß auch. Aber er liebt sein Land. Das Gejama nach den Landtagswahlen im Osten war sehr groß. Ich kann das verstehen. Aber die Politiker hören nicht zu und wissen überhaupt nicht, was die Menschen wollen. Deswegen sind die Wahlen so ausgegangen, wie sie ausgegangen sind. Da muss man sich nicht wundern.
Bevor wir das kommentieren, wir wollen ja niemandem auf den Leib gehen. Vor ein oder zwei Jahren haben wir noch ganz große Angstwellen geschoben, dass demnächst im Superwahljahr 60 Prozent der Welt wählt. Amerika ist dran, Europa hat schon gewählt, Thüringen und so weiter. Dass es eine riesige AI-Welle gibt mit Deepfakes und so weiter, können wir wirklich sicher ausschließen. Gab es hierzu Bekenner-Videos, die das nochmal verifizieren?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich würde sagen, für eine AI sieht die Perücke zu artificiell aus. Das hätte man besser hinbekommen, wahrscheinlich digital. Was ja sehr erstaunlich ist, dass er tatsächlich Trump als denjenigen verkauft, der auf sein Land achtet und etwas für die Menschen tut und das auch dann gleich mit Söder und Friedrich Merz in Verbindung bringt und es aber auch immer noch so rahmt, dass er eigentlich unpolitisch ist. Also ich bin ja ganz froh, dass er jetzt nicht begonnen hat mit den Worten, ich bin eigentlich unpolitisch, aber ich habe etwas gegen Ausländer. Also das ist ja so der nächste Schritt.
Das hören wir nachher.
Das kommt vielleicht dann später. Es ist sehr erstaunlich, dass auch Heino jetzt mit 85 Jahren sich bemüßigt fühlt, so was von sich zu geben, oder?
Ja, Heino, auch Heino will seine Zukunft noch mal retten. Ich bin ja Experte dafür, dass auch 85-Jährige noch eine Lebenserwartung haben, die eben nicht null ist. Es wird ja immer leicht, nur weil er vier Jahre älter ist als die statistische Lebenserwartung aller. Es ist eben, Heino hat auch noch ein Recht auf Zukunft.
Ja, und ich hoffe, es wird aber eine Zukunft ohne Friedrich Merz sein. Die Debatten sind aber überall doch relativ blöde. Wir schauen uns einen Clip aus dem Presseclub an. Erstens da Malte Kreuzfeld von der Taz, der sagt, wir müssten mal investieren. Die Carola-Brücke in Dresden zeigt es nochmal ganz anschaulich. Dann ist dort aber die Journalistin, mit der ich auch schon da saß, Höning von der Rheinischen Post. Und die erklärt mal, was eigentlich das Problem ist.
Ich sage, sowohl diese Regierung als auch alle anderen werden ein massives Problem haben, wo dieses Geld herkommen soll, wenn man nicht entweder die Einnahmen erhöht oder vorübergehend doch höhere Schulden macht.
Wer das aus dem laufenden Haushalt rauszuschneiden, sehe ich nicht.
Wenn man es nicht schafft, jetzt die 3 Milliarden noch wegzunehmen, um die globale Minderausgabe wieder auf einen erträglichen Wert zu kriegen, wo man da 50 bis 100 Milliarden jedes Jahr herholen will.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihnen das auch so geht.
Ich spüre eine große Unruhe bei Frau Hömer.
Ja, das kann sein.
Ja, da möchte ich energisch widersprechen. Natürlich wäre es überhaupt kein Problem, aus dem Haushalt mehr Geld herauszuholen für Infrastrukturausgaben. Da müsste man nur den Mut haben, Prioritäten zu setzen. Ich sage ein Beispiel. Jede dritte Euro aus dem Haushalt geht für Soziales drauf. Wir haben das Bürgergeld zum Jahresanfang um 12 Prozent erhöht. Etwas, was sich jetzt als Fehler herausstellt. Das war viel zu hoch gemessen an der Inflationsentwicklung.
Also, was soll man dann noch machen? Also, ist nicht die gesamte Konzeption falsch? Also muss man sich nicht auch hier die Frage stellen, es hat keinen Sinn mehr, eine solche Position einzuladen. Also, man kann ja noch über die Position reden, was wäre außer Schulden zu machen, noch zu tun, um die Infrastruktur zu verbessern. Auf so eine Debatte kann man sich ja einlassen. Aber wenn man jetzt tatsächlich glaubt, dass man Brücken sanieren könnte, wenn man nur das Bürgergeld kürzt, das ist doch so an den Haaren herbeigezogen. Weil wir ja diese 100 Milliarden mal gerade gehört haben, wir wissen eigentlich, ist es noch viel mehr, was in die Hand genommen werden müsste. Dass das nicht geht, es sei denn, man würde ab morgen beschließen, niemand mehr Renten und Bürgergeld auszuzahlen und dann machen wir stattdessen Brücken, dann verbietet sich doch eigentlich dieses Argument. Hier kommt es aber so ungeheuer seriös daher, aber eigentlich ist das ja auch nicht gescheiter, als Heino da im roten Pulli von sich gibt.
Ja, dann sollen wir jetzt als Alternative vorschlagen, dass ja die ganzen Bürgergeldempfänger das Bürgergeld nicht mehr brauchen, wenn sie Arbeit haben und es gibt ja viel zu tun, wie zum Beispiel Brücken aufzubauen.
Das wäre eine schöne Idee, dann müsste der Staat allerdings als Unternehmer auftreten und das möchte er auf keinen Fall.
Bloß nicht öffentlich bauen.
Nein, nein, das sollte man nicht machen. Wir haben ja über Crazy Rich geredet. Du warst wahnsinnig begeistert.
Genau, das kann man ja nochmal. Sie hat jetzt gesagt, 30 Prozent des Haushalts geht für Soziales drauf. Das sind natürlich die ganzen Rentner. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Anrufsituation ist. Immer sehr interessant im Presseclub. Da rufen ja dann doch mal die Betroffenen selber an. Wir kennen ja jetzt die Zahlen. Wir haben Crazy Rich gelesen. Also 29 Prozent von allem gehört einem Prozent. Und mit 29 Prozent von allem sind eben 20 Billionen Euro gemeint. Und sie docktert jetzt an 30 Prozent von 450 Milliarden rum. Das ist ja auch, also das sieht man ja, kann man ja. Diese schönen, vielleicht ist das beste Bild dieses Toilettenrollen-Beispiel. Was die in Österreich in dieser Debatte haben. Also man stellt sich das ganze Vermögen als Toilettenrolle vor, Toilettenpapierrolle. Und dann verteilt man das so, wie es tatsächlich verteilt ist in der Gesellschaft. Und dann gibt man so ein ganz kleines Zipfelchen, das man kaum sieht, an die ersten zehn Leute, die da stehen. Dann so zwei halbe Blättchen an noch zwei. Und die ganze restliche Rolle kriegt dann einer.
Genau.
Das ist die Verteilung. Und sie will jetzt bei den drei Leuten, die so ein ganz kleines unsichtbares Zipfelchen, da nochmal ein Zipfelchen, 30 Prozent wegnehmen.
Und dann steht die Carola-Brücke wieder.
Was für uns ja bedeutet, wenn wir das nächste Mal in den Presseklub eingeladen werden, immer eine Rolle Toilettenpapier mitnehmen.
Und dann rausholen.
Mit der Sendung rausholen und das einmal visualisieren.
Einmal über den Tisch rollen und so. Sehr schöne Idee. Ich vermute, wir bekommen jetzt keine Anfrage mehr nach diesem Vorschlag. So viel Subversion ist am 12 Uhr mittags in der ARD doch nicht erwünscht. Nun war es ja so bei dem Crazy Rich Buch, dass du übermäßig begeisterst warst für meine Begriffe. Ich war ein bisschen gedämpft und sagte, na ja, Julia Friedrichs geht vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu lieb mit den Reichen um, beziehungsweise müsste man nicht mit mehr Vehemenz nochmal zeigen, wie skandalös das eigentlich ist, was da vor sich geht. Ja, und dann habe ich gedacht, na ja, vielleicht ist aber auch der Diskurs im Ganzen noch lange nicht so weit, wie wir es jetzt sind. Und mit wir meine ich jetzt alle auch die Zürnen, die natürlich in diese Debatten eingelesen sind oder eingehört sind. Denn hörte ich mir nämlich bei Der Zeit einen Podcast an, der heißt Was liest du gerade? Und da ist Alexander Kamann. Und der spricht auch über das Buch Crazy Rich. Und wir hören uns mal so ein paar Ausschnitte aus diesem Podcast an.
Sind Superreiche insgesamt wirklich so ein Problem? Weil es gibt ja auch Soziologen, die sagen, Superreiche gab es schon immer, gar kein Problem, weil das Normgebende oder die richtigen Ungleichheitsgeschichten kommen eigentlich durch die Masse der Wohlhabenden darunter. Weil das eine ganz große Menge ist. Und das prägt eine Gesellschaft dann noch stärker in der Spaltung. Und diese 3.300 Superreiche sind bei 80 Millionen. Macht nicht die Spaltung einer Gesellschaft aus. Das machen eher dann die 10 Millionen anderen, die quasi auch deutlich reicher sind. Auch vom Erbe her und vom Wohlhabenden her.
Ich verstehe das Argument nur so halb. Also ich würde auch sagen, ja, man kann sich nicht nur auf diese Superreichen konzentrieren. Da macht man sich auch einen schlanken Fuß. Aber zugleich ist ja die Ungleichheit in der Gesellschaft daran besonders gut ablesbar. Weil die es ja auch am Ende sind, die zum Beispiel deshalb immer reicher werden, weil sie einfach nochmal höhere Renditen haben wollen. Und das führt zu beispielsweise Mieterhöhungen. Das gilt auch für Millionäre, Multimillionäre, selbstverständlich, die hier anspricht. Aber ich finde es erstaunlich, dass er sagt, nein, diesen jetzt eigentlich doch nicht das Problem. Und dann geht er noch so einen Schritt weiter und kommt in so einen nationalen Vergleich.
Sich das Vermögen in den nächsten 50 Jahren und so weiter akkumulieren wird eben bei ganz wenigen.
Und dass diese Unterschiede größer werden.
Das stimmt. Diese Rechnung macht sie auf. Ja, sag ich wieder, naja, mal gucken, was die chinesischen Superreichen dazu sagen, ob sie nicht die anderen dann hinter sich lassen, die Deutschen. Aber wie auch immer.
Was machen wir jetzt? Also sagen wir jetzt, naja, das sind aber unsere Superreichen. Und dann hilft das uns ja dann doch. Und nicht, dass die Chinesen irgendwann mehr Superreiche haben als wir. Das ist so ein bisschen auch dieses Oschmann-Argument, der sagte, im Osten, da gehören alle großen Immobilien Westlern. Und du sagst ja dann zurecht, ja, ich gehe zwar hier durch Frankfurt und kann sagen, gehört alles den Westlern, nur leider nicht mir.
Ja, eben. Hätte man natürlich im Wahlkampf mal, also ihn mal drauf festnageln können, konfrontieren, wie er das Argument auf die Straße bringt. Beispielsweise in einem Wahlkampf, wenn er dann durch Leipzig geht und sagt, ich weiß es nicht, aber es sind unsere Superreichen. Noch mal einen besonderen Fokus drauflegen.
Letzter Clip und jetzt wird es wirklich schlimm.
Das Hauptproblem ist ja immer, dass diese Superreichen seit Menschengedenken das hinterlassen, was wir heute noch schätzen. Also sämtliche Schlösser oder Pyramiden oder wie auch immer diese Welt sind hinterlassen von eben solchen Superreichen. Und das muss man zumindest irgendwie immer so selber noch im Blick haben und dann geht's los.
Und deswegen möchte ich ein bisschen Abbitte leisten. Also Julia Friedrich muss auch erst mal wirklich Grundlagen legen. Also wahrscheinlich muss sie so zögerlich sein, weil dann viele noch auf einem ganz anderen, sagen wir, Erkenntnisstand sind.
Aber vergegenwärtigt er das Argument noch? Also ich verstehe ja, das ist eine keine Ahnung, altes Schloss, das kann man heute noch besuchen als Tourist. Aber was hinterlassen uns die Superreichen heute gerade? Also wir haben über Jachten gesprochen, nicht mal da.
Na ja, es werden ja irgendwelche großen Gebäude gebaut und da kann man sich in 100 Jahren noch drüber freuen. Ich würde, weil ich das wirklich so irrsinnig fand, jetzt mal für drei Minuten Deutschunterricht machen wollen. Und zwar werde ich jetzt ein Gedicht vorlesen von Berthold Precht, das die meisten wahrscheinlich kennen, aber Alexander Kamann wahrscheinlich nicht. Und dieses Gedicht heißt Fragen eines lesenden Arbeiters. Und dieses Gedicht geht so. Wer baute das siebenturige Theben? In den Büchern stehen die Namen von Königinnen. Haben die Könige die Felsbrocken herbeigeschleppt? Und das mehrmals zerstörte Babylon. Wer baute es so viele Male auf? In welchen Häusern des goldstrahlenden Lima wohnten die Bauleute? Wohin gingen an dem Abend, wo die chinesische Mauer fertig war, die Maurer? Das große Rom ist voll von Triumphbögen. Wer errichtete sie? Über wen triumphierten die Cäsaren? Hatte das vielbesungene Byzanz nur Paläste für seine Bewohner? Selbst in dem sagenhaften Atlantis brüllten in der Nacht, wo das Meer es verschlang, die Ersaufenden nach ihren Sklaven. Der junge Alexander eroberte Indien. Er allein? Cäsar schlug die Galia. Hatte er nicht wenigstens einen Koch bei sich? Philipp von Spanien weinte, als seine Flotte untergegangen war. Weinte sonst noch jemand? Friedrich II siegte im Siebenjährigen Krieg. Wer siegte außer ihm? Jede Seite ein Sieg. Wer kocht den Siegesschmaus? Alle zehn Jahre ein großer Mann. Wer bezahlte die Spesen? So viele Berichte, so viele Fragen. Immer noch aktuell. Und man denkt, das müsste doch jetzt wenigstens nicht mehr als Argument herhalten können, dass man noch mal sagt, aber die Reichen haben doch so viel errichtet. Also das stimmt natürlich mitunter, dass die auch mal dann ein Museum oder so bauen. Aber wir haben ja gesehen, diese Steuerersparnisse sind so groß, man müsste ja halb Deutschland mit Museen pflastern, um das aufzuholen.
Ich frage mich eh, was im Kopf vorgeht, wenn man das Buch liest und dann weiß, man redet danach drüber. Also man ist sowohl in Interaktion gefangen als auch vor Publikum. Und dann überlegt man sich, was könnte ich anführen? Und dann kommt man relativ früh auf so eine Idee. Also dafür braucht man ja das Buch nicht, dass man einfach sagt, ja, hat sie zu bereichenden, was könnte denn der Pro-Argument sein? Ah ja, genau, die haben ja Sachen erschaffen. Und wie man es dann trotzdem durchhält, durch die Lektöre des Buches, durch das Gespräch, um dann zu entscheiden, jetzt ist der richtige Moment, das anzufügen. Absurd.
Deine Frage war ja berechtigt, was erschaffen die eigentlich heute? Oder wir können uns ja fragen, wie arbeiten die eigentlich? In dem Buch spielen ja Family Offices eine wichtige Rolle. Und ich glaube, das sollten wir auch noch häufiger in den Blick nehmen. Und da ist jetzt gerade ein neuer Podcast erschienen von David Döbele. Das ist auch so ein Investor-Coach, weiß ich nicht was. Der hatte Robin Binder zu Gast. Der ist bei so einem Family Office angestellt. Und der erzählt hier mal so ein bisschen, wie das alles läuft.
Brutal breit. Also ich habe da Sachen gemacht, das hätte ich nie gedacht, irgendwie vor 10 Jahren oder selbst vor 5 Jahren. Wir hatten bestand auch eine Immobilie in New York mit einem Partner gekauft. Dann habe ich den Verkaufsprozess von so einer Bürogeschäftsmobilie in New York begleitet. Da hat auch ein zweistelliger Umtrag verkauft in New York. Ich hatte halt null Ahnung, irgendwie, was mache ich mit dem Recht dort? Da dann reinfuchsten und es halt wie, ja, so ein bisschen Monopoly wäre jetzt irgendwie so. Also, wenn du ein bisschen Monopoly investierst, dann...
Ja, einfach ein bisschen Monopoly spielt man.
Ich meine, wir haben ja besprochen, wie die... Da kann ich übrigens eine Wortschöpfung von meinem kleinen Sohn, der war mit seinem Freund bei mir zu Hause. Und ich hab ihn dann so, als er anfing mit Papa, ich hab Durst und hier, hab ich gesagt, ja, du verhältst dich wie so ein Millionär. Du willst einfach Sachen. Und dann kam die drauf zu sagen, ja, ich bin ein Willionär. Und jetzt haben wir ja dieses Metier der Willionäre. Sie kriegen immer genau, was sie wollen. Und wenn die von sich aus denken, dass ich eine Immobilie kaufe, wie ein Hotel in Monopoly, dann wird das natürlich für die genauso veranstaltet. Dann sitzen einfach alle da und spielen mit denen Monopoly. Und dann kaufen die halt Häuser.
Oder Kunst, auch ein interessantes Thema.
Investierst du in ein Unternehmen, dann hast du irgendwie einen Gründer-Pitch bei dir, ein Gründerteam, sagst du ja cool, Mama, investieren wir irgendwie 100.000 Euro, finden wir gut, da sind wir ein bisschen dabei. Und dann kaufst du Kunstwerke, dann guckst du ja Kunst. Wir brauchen jetzt gerade Liquidität, wir wollen irgendwas verkaufen, so ne, lass doch mal gucken, welche Banken beleihen Kunstwerke? Dann guckst du halt, okay, welche Banken gibt es, die Kunstwerke beleihen, dann gibt es verschiedene Rahmendaten, manchmal kannst du an der Wand hängen lassen, manchmal muss es in Lager und manchmal ist es Recourse, manchmal ist es Non-Recourse, also mit oder ohne Haftung. Das ist schon cool, also mega vielfältig.
Ja, also wer Lust hat, kann da auch mitmachen vielleicht im Family Office.
Das finde ich richtig gut. Also du willst Kunst kaufen?
Nein, die haben schon Kunst und die wollen Liquidität. Und dann sagen die, dann beleihen wir das mal kurz. Ihr könnt es auch zu Hause stehen lassen oder im Museum hängen lassen. Dann gibt es von der Bank Liquidität und dann haben sie ein bisschen Cash, können damit wieder ein neues Investment machen und wenn sie das wieder draußen haben, dann lösen sie das wieder aus.
Das finde ich eigentlich gut. Vielleicht kam es auch deswegen zu diesen kurzen, wie hieß das, als sie alle nur noch virtuelle Kunst tätigen. NFT's. Genau, NFT's. Vielleicht ist das gar nicht so ein großer, wie wir mal denken, Umschwung zum NFT gewesen. Weil die Gegenseite hat ja dann einfach, ja, wir hätten ja 30 Millionen, hätten sie Kunst dafür? Und dann sagen die, ja, wie gestückelt denn? Sieben Stücke oder zehn? Ich kann ihnen auch ein Paket mit 15 machen. Und dann ist die Frage, interessiert sie dann, was das ist? Nee, können sie es abholen? Nee, lass es einfach hängen. Ich will nur den Eigentumstitel. Also sie haben sowieso immer nur NFT-Titel gehandelt. Und dann haben sie es halt wirklich virtualisiert.
Es ist verrückt auch, wenn wir auf die Immobilien blicken.
Oder auch Real Estate fand ich auch super spannend. Real Estate Leasing fand ich cool. Was wir da gemacht haben, da sagst du, ich habe Immobilien, die will ich nicht verkaufen, will aber die stillen Reserven heben, dann verkaufe ich die einfach an mich selber, heb die stillen Reserven und lease zurück mit einer anderen Gesellschaft von mir, was da alles möglich ist. Also es sind wirklich keine, also gefühlt keine Grenzen gesetzt, was du mit so Financial Engineering alles machen kannst.
Financial Engineering.
Ja und natürlich auch immer steueroptimiert, das ist das Stichwort. Er sagt dann noch was ganz Entscheidendes, denn viele überlegen jetzt auch schon, kann ich da mitmischen mit meinen paar Mark? Eher nicht und darauf kommt es ja dann eigentlich an.
Es war eher so, die Produkte waren halt so cool. Wenn du da so drüber redest, ja wir haben jetzt irgendwie ein Kunstwerk gekauft, ist dann noch Berlin, dann nochmal Kunst gekauft, ist verkauft und jetzt cool, kann ich da mitmachen oder wird investiert in einen Private Equity ford, Venture Capital ford. Das ist ja alles schwierig da den Zugang zu bekommen. Das habe ich so gelernt, alles am Kapitalmarkt, gerade im Asset Management ist Zugang. Wenn du viele Leute kennst und da Zugang hast, dann hast du auch herausragende Returns. Also einfach bessere Returns mit Zugang zu anderen Produkten.
Ja, also wenn man 100 Millionen hat, ist es leichter auf 200 Millionen zu kommen, als von einer Million auf zwei Millionen. Also das ist auch nochmal tatsächlich dieser fundamentale Unterschied zwischen den Reichen und den Superreichen, dass diese Zugänge für reiche Leute, also für einfache Millionären, nicht vorhanden sind.
Ja, dieser schöne Spruch, der Unterschied zwischen einer Million und einer Milliarde, ist eine Milliarde.
Ja, sehr richtig. Wir haben ja jetzt in den vergangenen Ausgaben und im Salon häufig über Demokratie diskutiert und die Fragen des ökosozialen Projekts, des ökoemanzipatorischen Projekts von Blüdon diskutiert. Das werden wir heute nicht wieder machen, keine Sorge.
Aber, weil ihr alle keine Fans von diesem Quatsch seid.
Aha, da gibt es also...
Aber er guckt ja auch Stefan Raab, das ist die selbe Ecke.
Aber da gab es noch mehr Applaus. Ich weiß, ich bin nicht alleine. Aber dann wollen wir uns doch jetzt mal so einem progressiven Lager widmen. Jetzt wollen wir noch mal die große Transformation gestalten und so. Und ich meine es jetzt gar nicht zynisch, sondern es war so, dass ich mehrere E-Mails bekam. Manche gingen auch an dich. Ob wir nicht dieses Buch von Hedwig Richter und Bernd Ulrich machen wollen, Demokratie und Revolution. Und da gab es ja auch sehr heiße Kämpfe in den Vögel-Tons. Hedwig Richter gegen Jürgen Kaube. Jürgen Kaube schießt zurück. Am Ende hat man sich vorgeworfen, wer die meisten Schnitzel essen kann.
Wer hat da gewonnen?
Damals, weiß ich nicht. Es gab jedenfalls damals schon eine Debatte, also vor einigen Wochen. Und nun waren sie beim Bruno Kreisky Forum zu Gast. Robert Miesek hat moderiert. Und dann dachte ich mir, jetzt stelle ich mich mal dieser Debatte. Was wollen die eigentlich mit dem Buch? Die ersten nahezu 30 Minuten des Gesprächs verlaufen so, dass noch mal geschildert wird, wie dramatisch es ist und was alles noch nicht erkannt wurde. Und dass es mit technischer Innovation allein nicht geht. Also das, was allgemein bekannt ist, wurde dann noch mal wiederholt. Deswegen hören wir uns diese Clips jetzt nicht an. Dann kommt ein erstes sehr eigenartiges Argument, als es um technischen Fortschritt und E-Fuels geht, von Hedwig Richter.
Das Paris-Abkommen wurde ohne Militär gemacht. Also die ganzen Länderziele hat man das Militär rausgenommen. Sonst hätte das wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktioniert. Militär ist sehr, sehr energieintensiv. Und wie kriegt man Panzer dahin, dass sie CO2-neutral werden müssen? Also die demokratischen Armeen legen alle grüne Pläne vor zur CO2-Neutralität. Aber bisher ist das wirklich Greenwashing. Panzer können nicht mit Batterien fahren. Es wird keine Steckdosen an den Fronten geben und so weiter und so weiter. Also brauchen sie E-Fuels. Und all das ist völlig außerhalb des Blickfeldes, völlig außerhalb der Rechnungen. Also das ist ein ganz, ganz kleiner Aspekt, den man unterschätzt, der wichtig ist, aber der einfach zeigt, dass es ganz grundlegende Umstellungen geben muss. Oder ich sage immer, wenn ich mit FDP-Menschen zu tun habe, die sagen, ja, mein Porsche, das ist gut und ich werde den mit E-Fuels betanken, dann sage ich immer, tut mir leid, aber die E-Fuels, die hergestellt werden, die werden sehr wahrscheinlich alle für die Armee gebraucht.
Und in dem Moment sind mir FDP-Leute sympathisch. Dann möchte ich die E-Fuels lieber im Porsche.
Ich will kurz ein höherer Erlebnis wie ich, das jetzt gehört ab Schildern. Vielleicht geht es jemandem auch so. Ich habe gehört, Paris wurde ohne Militär gemacht. Ja, das war die Klimaabkundung. Im Sinne von, die Welt hat sich darauf geeinigt, ohne dass jemand mit Militär bedroht werden musste, diesen Völkerrechts...
Ach so, nein, nein, nein. Also, dass das Militär als Klimafaktor nicht mit am Tisch saß und man darüber nachgedacht hat, wie bekommt man in Zukunft klimaneutrale Kriege hin?
Ja, ich dachte, man hat händeringend nochmal ein positives Argument gesucht.
Während Ulrich knüpfte aber auch da dann an.
Das ist überhaupt keine Kleinigkeit. Das ist so ein typisches Beispiel dafür, weil die Technik Euphorie aus der Misantropie kommt und nicht aus der Kenntnis der Sache, werden bestimmte Dinge einfach nicht diskutiert. Also, dann sagt die FDP und CDU ja auch, wir müssen technologieoffen sein, deswegen muss der Verbrennungsmotor auch seine Chance haben. Warum das ökonomisch ist, also so. Und dann stellt man sich eben vor, wir haben dann einen Verbrennungsmotor und dann wird er weitergebaut und noch verfeinert. Und am Ende kommen dann aber, weil er damit CO2 neutral ist, kommen dann E-Fuels da rein. Und dann kommt eben Hedwig und sagt, ja tut mir leid, aber die E-Fuels, die kommen leider in die Panzer. Und so viele E-Fuels können wir, das ist wirklich reine Halluzination.
Also ohne Aufrüstung geht es nicht, aber die wollen wir klimaneutral mit E-Fuels gestalten. Das ist also jetzt das progressive Lager, das sich hier, also pseudo-progressive Lager. Also ich will jetzt nicht wirkliche Klimaaktivisten mit dazu zählen, die führen natürlich andere Debatten. Nur es ist so erstaunlich, wenn man das hier hört. So und jetzt geht diese Diskussion weiter. Und die Frage ist ja, was wollen sie mit ihrem Buch? Also nur noch mal aufzuschreiben, dass das mit der Klimakatastrophe dramatisch ist und dass zu wenig getan wird. Das wissen wir alle. Das wurde jetzt auch 30 Minuten gesagt. Jetzt soll es darum gehen, was kann man denn tun? Jetzt sagt Blüdon, das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt ist gescheitert, weil diese Begrenzung, die das eigentlich verlangt, nicht zusammengeht mit der Entgrenzung der Selbstverwirklichung. Jetzt wollen Bernd Ulrich und Petrich Richter, was genau, fragen wir uns?
Aber wie kriegt man es dann hin? Es ist doch logisch. Wir brauchen eine relativ massive Anstrengung von Menschen, von denen der Großteil davon nichts haben wird.
Ja, und das ist eben diese Revolution. Ich hatte das vorhin angesprochen. Wir können Demokratie nicht länger als was plebizitär, konsumorientiertes Unternehmen propagieren. Das ist nicht, dass wir jetzt antikapitalistisch, dass wir glauben, alles lässt sich dadurch lösen, dass man den Kapitalismus abschafft. Wie sollen wir das hinkriegen? Generalstreik oder wie?
Also irgendwie muss aber eine Revolution her? Weiter?
Die Frage, die ja völlig berechtigt ist an uns, woher nimmt ihr eigentlich die Energie für die Revolution her? Und da würde ich sagen, die Energie kommt jetzt nicht aus der Wärmepumpe. Also kaufen sie sich alle Wärmepumpe, aber das wird sondern aus den Menschen. Also wir sagen, dann wird uns immer vorgeworfen, also jeder, der auch was auf sich hält, sagt, der Mensch ist halt so, der Mensch ist halt egoistisch und so weiter und so weiter. Wir sagen nicht, dass der Mensch, also die sagen, der Mensch ist böse. Wir sagen, der Mensch ist gut, so ist es nicht. Sondern wir sagen nur, mehr brauchen wir nicht für unsere Energie sozusagen, für unsere demokratische Energie, als dass so gut wie alle Menschen sich gerne eine einigermassen gute Geschichte über sich selbst erzählen wollen.
Wenn die Leute erkennen, dass sie eine gute Geschichte über sich selbst erzählen wollen, und die darf offenbar nicht in der S-Klasse spielen, diese Geschichte.
Auch im Porsche fallen Tränen. Ich habe das Video jetzt durch Stefan Raab gesehen.
Ganz richtig. Dann, wenn man erkennt, dass man diese gute Geschichte erzählen will, dann kommt die Energie in einem, die man freisitzt, um die Klimarevolution. Also ich verstehe das nicht. Also ich meine, das eine ist eine Politologin, die sich mit Demokratiegeschichte seit Jahr und Tag beschäftigt. Das andere ist ein Journalist, der sich mit Klimafragen, mit der Grünen Partei seit Jahr und Tag in der Zeit beschäftigt. Man kann doch dann nicht darauf kommen, dass es wohl Energie und gute Geschichten sind. Also man kann ja diese Idee haben, das wissen wir von Rudra Brechmann, so ähnlich zumindest, dass der Mensch wahrscheinlich nicht ein Monster ist, wie er uns zeigt, aber man muss ja über systemische Bedingtheiten dann nachdenken. Also warum verhalten sich Leute zum Beispiel, als seien sie in Konkurrenzverhältnissen, naja dann, wenn sie in Konkurrenzverhältnissen auch tatsächlich sind, zum Beispiel. Aber wenn man doch nur von so guten Geschichten, also ich frage mich auch, wie macht man das? Also geht man jetzt raus beim Wahlkampf, sagt wollen sie eigentlich mal eine gute Geschichte über sich erzählen? Dann habe ich eine Wärmepumpe für sie.
Ich stimme deinem Subtext zu. Ich bin auch dafür, dass sich jeder, der in Diskussionen eingeladen ist, dort ernsthafte Gedanken über sein Thema macht, statt nur spontan zu kommentieren, was passiert. Sonst fällt auf, dass es da eine Wesensgleichheit gibt zwischen dem, was wir machen und dem, woran wir uns abarbeiten. Und wenn Hildwig Richter sagt, sie macht Demokratie Geschichte und Bernd Ulrich ist Journalist, dann macht er halt Demokratie Geschichten. Vielleicht ist es nicht komplizierter als...
Ja, wir hören uns mal nochmal an, wie das ist mit dieser narrativen Wende.
Und wir sind jetzt in einem narrativen Nirwana sozusagen angekommen. Also eigentlich, wir reden uns aber immer noch ein, dass das nicht so ist. Und jetzt sind wir in dieser Absturz, dass wir eben nicht mehr... Also im Grunde war es ja vorher so, haben wir uns eingeredet, auch wenn wir egoistisch sind selber, alles, was wir anfassen, wird irgendwie Gemeinwohl. Und jetzt lernen wir langsam. Und das ist schrecklich, alles, was wir anfassen, wird zu Zerstörung. Und das ist der Zustand, und das ist auch der Monster-Dialog, das ist der Zustand, den wir uns befinden.
Seit wann hat man geglaubt, dass alles, was wir anfassen, zu Gemeinwohl wird? Und jetzt stimmt das nicht mehr. Also das ist mir völlig neu. Also mir ist neu, dass man in den 60er-Jahren wirtschaftet, auf die Arbeit ging oder in den Unternehmen betrieb und sagte, alles Gemeinwohl. Also was ist da los?
Ich erlebe auch gerade so einen Absturz. Bernd Ulrich habe ich ja zehn Jahre lang dafür, ich will sagen, gehatet, dass er immer nur Angela Merkel sagt. Also es liegt alles Angela Merkel. Jetzt sehen wir eigentlich, das stimmt ja gar nicht. Und eigentlich war er eher der große, wie soll ich sagen, Nacherzähler, der dann plötzlich mit dieser Wortschöpfung, ich habe sie schon mal im Podcast ernannt, Work-Life-Weltgeschehen-Balance. Also das Weltgeschehen erdrückt uns quasi. Bis unter die Bettdecke können wir keine persönliche Balance finden, weil uns das Weltgeschehen mit seinen Narrativen, und jetzt ist plötzlich ein narratives Nirvana.
Ja, weil wir die neuen Narrative brauchen.
Und ich überlege tatsächlich, ob ich abso, Also für dich gibt es Sinn, was er sagt, meinst du.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Und deswegen überlege ich auch, ob es sinnvoll wäre, ab sofort auf das Wort Narrativ zu verzichten. Und vielleicht kann man es auch in die, nein, dass man es wirklich in diesem, hier im Podcast, dass wenn einer von uns beiden sagt, dass man wirklich eine Strafe zahlen muss. Dass wir wirklich nicht mehr Narrativ sagen.
Aber es ist ja viel schlimmer.
Es ist so präsent, dass man doch aus so einer Hilflosigkeit immer mal wieder Narrativ einstreut. Und das müssen wir uns untersagen.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass wir so viel vom Narrativ sprechen.
Nicht oft. Aber hin und wieder haben die uns schon geknackt. Und dann sprechen wir auch davon.
Wir haben uns infiziert. Eigentlich ist ja der Narrativbegriff schon seit einer Weile so ein bisschen verbrämt, oder wie man das nennt. Und eigentlich hat man ihn ja auch nur verwendet, weil er ein bisschen cooler klingt. Weshalb ich ja eigentlich seit einer Weile bedauert, dass er auch der Begriff der Erzählung plötzlich so eine Konjunktur hat.
Also es ist, ja jetzt hören wir uns hier noch so eine Befreiungsgeschichte an.
Und was kann wichtiger sein und schöner sein, als dass wir uns aus diesem Zustand befreien, aus diesem Alptruck befreien und dem wir sagen, wir versuchen zusammen aus der Zerstörung rauszukommen. Wir haben die Kraft dazu. Wir brauchen dafür Technik. Wir brauchen dafür Politik. Wir brauchen dafür, wie Hedwig das immer wieder sagt, einen neuen Glauben in die Demokratie, der ja teilweise auch ein Alterglaube ist. Wir sind ja in einer Konsumorientierung, dass die Demokratie muss liefern. Nein, die Demokratie ist die Lieferung. Also wir können zusammen rauskommen aus diesem Alptruck. Das ist die Energie und die wird aber bisher nicht mobilisiert, weil die Politik und die Öffentlichkeit immer noch in dem Monsterdialog verfangen ist oder in der Technoillusion oder in der Misanthropie. Aber ich glaube, in dem Moment, wo man es ausspricht, wenn wir darüber reden, in welcher Lage wir uns wirklich befinden, dann kommt die Gartenzaungütigkeit der Menschen zum Tragen anstatt ihre Politverhetztheit.
Also die Gartenzaungütigkeit der Menschen, das ist ja dieses Brechmann-Argument. Wenn wir Menschen direkt begegnen, dann verhalten wir uns anders zu ihnen und dann sind wir uns eigentlich nicht feindlich gesinnt und foltern uns gegenseitig und was weiß ich. Aber was ja hier nochmal so deutlich wird, ist, dass er eigentlich nur eine narrative Wende will und glaubt, damit kommt die Wende. Aber diese narrative Wende allein, das zeigt es ja gerade, hilft ja nichts. Also Habeck nimmt ja jetzt stündlich neue Videos auf, in denen er nochmal irgendwas neu erklärt, um eine narrative Wende eigentlich herbeizureden, die er nicht dann einsetzt. Also es ist ja nicht einfach, ich verändere mein Bewusstsein und hoffe, dass das mein Nachbar auch so tut. Und dann wird diese Klimatransformation schon funktionieren.
Ich glaube, Bernd Ohlrich sieht einfach im Zeitgeist, dass eine Lücke gerade aufgeht für ihn. Jetzt, wo Habermas aussortiert wird, möchte er in, aber der Sprechakt reinrutschen.
Ja, und hier würde ich auch nochmal Blüthorn recht geben, dass man doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, jetzt pass mal auf. Denn er sagt schon, es hat mit Verzicht zu tun. Aber auch dieser Verzicht ist eigentlich eine Befreiungsgeschichte.
Ich würde es mal umgekehrt sagen. Wie kam eigentlich die Idee, dass etwas so großes wie die ökologische Wende ohne Verzicht möglich in die Welt? Weil wir sind ja, hier sind alles Erwachsene. Wir wissen, nichts, was wichtig ist in unserem Leben, geht ohne Verzicht. Nicht der berufliche Aufstieg, nicht Gesundheit, nicht Kinder haben. Alles ist mit Verzicht verbunden. Nur in diesem Spezialdiskurs Ökologie soll das auf einmal nicht gelten. Also das ist schon mal eine merkwürdige Annahme. Aber mir geht es, ich werde mal versuchen, das darzustellen. Uns geht es ja um eine Befreiung. Befreiung aus einer Bedrückung. Insofern ist es sozusagen, im Einzelnen muss auf dieses oder jenes verzichten. Das ist schon klar, gewinnt dadurch aber auch andere Dinge.
Das ist interessant. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wir kennen ja unsere Clips nicht. Ich weiß aber, dass nachher die Boomer eine Rolle spielen.
Ja.
Und die Boomer kritisieren ja gerade, dass die Jungen, nachdem man ihnen den Verzicht auf Gehalt aufverzwungen hat, die sagen, ich könnte auch auf Arbeit verzichten. Also eigentlich machen die ja schon.
Ja, im Prinzip schon. Aber ich glaube nicht so, wie die beiden sich das vorstellen. Und hier wird auch der Verzicht wieder als eine Befreiung angesehen. Dann würde ich sagen, es gibt schon Arten von Verzichten, die sind nicht befreit. Die sind dann notwendig und die sind auch absolut sinnvoll, zum Beispiel auf gewisse Dinge mit Blick auf das Klima zu verzichten. Aber es ist nicht so gleich eine Befreiung. Also man kann dann sagen, ich fühle mich dann besser. Aber na ja, ist das so eine große Befreiung. Es ist auch eine sehr eigenartige Auffassung von Demokratie, muss ich hier feststellen.
Dass Politik sehr wohl Menschen überzeugen kann und das machen wir sehr, sehr stark. Wir leben in einer repräsentativen Demokratie, die eben nicht plebizit her gucken muss, was will die Mehrheit, was nicht. Sondern das sind die Verantwortlichen gewählt, auf vier Jahre in aller Regel. Und dann sind sie gewählt dafür, zum Wohle des Volkes zu handeln. Also sie sind dafür gewählt, dass sie auch eine gute ökologische Politik machen. Und dann eben, wenn Mehrheiten dagegen sind, ist es die Aufgabe von Politikerinnen, Politikern, aber auch von den, die in der Öffentlichkeit laut sind, die in einer Stellenverantwortung tragen, die Mehrheit zu gewinnen.
Aber das mag man jetzt nicht plebizitär nennen. Aber es ist doch so, dass die Politik in einer Demokratie, gerade in der Deutschen, so funktioniert, dass sie Mehrheiten benötigt, um überhaupt regieren zu können und dann auch noch gerne wiedergewählt werden möchte. Also dann irgendwann wieder eine Mehrheit haben möchte. Und ich kann doch jetzt nicht einfach sagen, naja, die sind dann gewählt und dann geht es ja darum, das Gemeinwohle und sonst was zu erfüllen. Ja, aber wenn es ja eine Partei oder drei Parteien gar nicht darum geht, zum Beispiel FDP und AfD, dann kann ich ja nicht einfach sagen, das spielt aber doch da gar keine Rolle.
Vor allem wir sehen doch jetzt in Thüringen, Sachsen, Brandenburg, wie kurz fünf Jahre sind, um zu sagen, die sind gewählt. Na ja, die können halt gewählt und abgewählt werden. Verstehe ich gar nicht, warum man das jetzt, Frau Hedwig, nochmal erklären muss. Ich dachte, sie müsste uns das erklären.
Ja, also es richtet sich ja schon nach der Mehrheit. Also nicht direkt, dass man jetzt jeden Tag ein Veto einlegen kann, wenn Berlin was beschlossen wird. Aber am Ende richtet es sich natürlich nach der Mehrheit. Und vielleicht hakt es auch daran, wenn eigentlich der Buchtitel gar nicht mit dem zusammenpasst, was man da so vertritt. Und damit will ich das jetzt abschließen. Robert Miesig fragt jetzt mal nach diesem Titel, Demokratie und Revolution.
Dass man sagt, wenn wir nur auf den Egoismus setzen, erstens gewinnen damit die Populisten ihre Stimmen, aber ihr nicht, die demokratischen Parteien nicht. Werdet realistisch.
Warum heißt eigentlich euer Buch Demokratie und Revolution?
Das war der Vorleger oder was? Oh, ne, ne, ne.
Blödeste Frage, die man überhaupt schämen kann. Nein, nein, nein.
Also weil wir eben, weil uns, genau, es sieht gut aus auf dem Cover. Und also einer unserer Ausgangspunkte war, dass wir gesagt haben, wir sollten zusammen ein Buch schreiben, weil ich eben sehr viel zur Demokratiegeschichte, mal Demokratieforscherin bin und mich davon überzeugt habe, erst auch in den letzten drei Jahren, wie unfassbar dramatisch die ökologische Krise ist und dass es nicht etwas ist, was in der Demokratie sich dann schon irgendwie lösen wird. Und dann haben wir gedacht, da müssen wir uns zusammentun. Dann war das einer, der sich schon sehr, sehr lange und sehr intensiv eben mit Ökologie im öffentlichen Diskurs auseinandersetzt, dass wir das da zusammenbringen können. Und dann wurde uns eben klar, ja die entscheidende Frage ist, kriegen Demokratien das hin? Und eben, dass wir das nicht ohne Revolution hinbekommen, Revolution im Denken und eben auch Revolution, die uns aus dieser zerstörerischen Normalität rausbringen.
Eine Revolution ist eine Umwälzung der herrschenden Ordnung. Und die Geschichte der Revolution zeigt, sie sind meistens mit Gewalt verbunden. Es war nicht so, dass man sich eines Morgens zusammen tat und gesagt hat, wir erzählen uns ab sofort neue Narrative. Und dann ändern sich die Grundlagen. Dann muss man einfach auf diesen Begriff verzichten. Dann kann man das Buch auch nennen, Demokratie und Veränderung. Geht ja auch. Aber dass diese inflationäre Begriffsverwendung von Revolution stattfindet, nervt ja sowieso. Aber dass man dann noch nicht mal auf die Frage antworten kann, ist doch schon zugleich ein Eingeständnis in das Scheitern dieses Projekts, das man da vorstellt.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, das mal so zu hören. Wir haben ja jetzt Bücher, also deine Titel, relativ plakativ, Influencer. Man fragt dann, was sind die Influencer. Man hofft, dass man es noch relativ vielen Leuten erklären kann. Also man will ja immer vom Titel aus in das Buch reinziehen. Für mich war es ja schon eine Vorfreude zu sagen, Rentnerrepublik, Altenrepublik. Ja, ja, sie lesen dann die Rentner, die Alten. Aber eigentlich geht es ja um die Republik. Das Alter in den Köpfen, wie auch immer. Es vererbt sich, man infiziert sich mit Alters, was auch immer Zuständen. Und dann kann man so Grundbegriffe erfinden, und sagt, Gemütszustand und so. Bei dem neuen Titel jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich den schon mal genannt habe, ich werde ihn nicht nennen. Nein. Freue ich mich genauso auf die Diskussion, weil das ist wieder zwei so...
Familie und Revolution schlage ich vor.
Genau. Es kommen weder Familie noch Revolutionen drin vor. Und das eine Wort ist sozusagen ein Stolperstein für das Wort, um das es eigentlich geht und so. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, wie man auf die Frage, warum haben sie ihr Buch so genannt, dann plötzlich sagen kann, ah ja, stimmt, der Verleger... Das ist ja eigentlich grotesk.
Ja, aber das ist der Stand der Debatten. Also ob das jetzt Heino ist oder Zeitjournalisten auf dem Panel mit Politologen, es ist doch alles ein bisschen enttäuschend gerade. Vielleicht ist deshalb diese Sehnsucht nach den 90ern groß, wo man eh nur Halligalli gemacht hat.
Apropos Halligalli, es gab diese Fernsehsendung, die Tage. Wir haben uns gedacht, als große Fans und Fürsprecher verteidigen neue Ideen wie zum Beispiel Bürgerräte.
Ja klar.
Müssen wir uns das angucken, wenn die ARD fragt, ist die AfD eigentlich ein Problem für die Demokratie? Ich weiß nicht genau, was der Beamer sieht, aber ihr könnt es auf diesen Vorhängen sehen, dass am Rande dieses Feldes überlebensgroß zweimal der Titel der Sendung genannt ist. Links im dramatischen Rot lautet dann die Antwort, ist die AfD eigentlich eine Gefahr für die Demokratie? Nein. Und auf der rechten Seite, ja. Ist ja auch mit den Signalfaden Rot und Blau markiert. Trotzdem erklärt uns nochmal Ingo Zamparoni das Spielprinzip. Wir dachten, wir gucken mal so die...
Und da sind hundert Bürger gecastet worden. Das ist jetzt eine Twitter-Debatte. Sind da auch Statisten dabei? Wurde da irgendjemand gelenkt oder so?
Das blenden wir mal aus.
Das blenden wir völlig aus. Aber hundert Leute, die jetzt auf so Feldern, wie bei 1, 2 oder 3 quasi hin und her wandern können, in welcher Position sie sich eher anschließen. Ich sag gleich dazu, du hattest das angekündigt, dass du das machen willst.
Ich hab dich gefragt, wieso du geguckt hast.
Ich hab's mir dann gestern Abend noch angesehen und hab mir aber ordentlich einen reingeknallt dabei. Und das war, glaub ich, nicht schlecht.
Also eigentlich braucht man hier gar keine weitere Erklärung, denn wir wissen eins, zwei oder drei, ob ihr wirklich richtig seht, seht ihr, wenn das Licht angeht, blablabla. 13 Fragen kennt man ja auch. Wir positionieren uns auf dem Feld, je nachdem, wie wir uns und so. Die Signalfarben, die Pfeile, die uns zeigen, okay, da kann man sich irgendwie so zuverhalten. Ingo erklärt nochmal die Spielregeln.
Liebe 100, ich werde sie gleich bitten, sich hier auf unserem Spielfeld zu verteilen. Und je mehr sie finden, ja, die AfD ist eigentlich ein Problem für die Demokratie. Desto mehr hier auf der blauen Seite, auf der Scala bis 3, sich zu verteilen. Und wenn sie denken, nein, das Gegenteil, die AfD ist eigentlich nicht so ein Problem, je nachdem hier auf der roten Seite sich zu verteilen.
So, jetzt hast du die Frage aufgeworfen, Demokratie, Revolution, wo schwanken die hin und her? Die AfD will ja auch so ein bisschen Revolution, keine Ahnung, also hier steht sozusagen alles auf dem, und sie nennen das auch Spielfeld. Und obwohl das Setting so einfach ist, geht die Sendung so weiter?
Hier drüben sind doch eine ganze Reihe auf der Position 3 in dem Feld. Darf ich Sie mal kurz fragen, warum haben Sie sich hierhin gestellt?
Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht sicher, ob ich richtig stehe. Ich bin eigentlich sehr dafür, dass die AfD an die Macht kommt und bin automatisch zu blau gegangen.
Ah, sehen Sie mal, Sie sind nicht von der Farbe. Dann müssen Sie eigentlich auf die andere Seite. Aber während Sie das machen, kann ich Sie fragen, warum Sie dafür sind?
Weil ich der Meinung bin, dass sich was verändern muss, definitiv, es muss sich was verändern im Land. Und es ist auch nicht fair, wenn man einfach alle, die die AfD gewählt haben, ausgrenzt. Ich bin dafür, dass eine schöne Koalition aus der CDU und der AfD entsteht.
Wir betonen die schöne Koalition.
Schöne, ja. Keine hässliche Koalition.
Also die ARD ist ja auch Veranstalter des Deutschlandtrends, die dann immer die Leute los schicken, um zu sagen, Exit-Poll, sagen Sie uns noch mal, was Sie gewählt haben. Und ich hätte jetzt gerne zusätzlich auch eine Auswertung der Frage, warum haben Sie das gewählt? Wie haben Sie vorher gewählt? Denn so wie das, also Leute gehen in eine Fernsehsendung, wissen, worauf sie sich einlassen, kriegen das erklärt.
Und die haben ja das schon noch mal durchgeprobt.
Es wird geprobt, mit Licht, ohne Licht und so weiter. Und dann klappt es trotzdem nicht. Man müsste ehrlicherweise die Deutschen auch noch mal fragen, so was haben Sie jetzt gewählt? Linke, warum haben Sie das gewählt? Und dann kommt das Antwort, weil Sie den Höcker jetzt mal an der Macht sehen wollen.
Ja, ich habe es ja schon hundertmal gesagt, die Nachbarin, die mir damals in Rheinland-Pfalz wohnhaft versicherte, dass sie Stoiber wählen wird als Ministerpräsident. Ich meine, ich habe ihr viel Glück dabei gewünscht. Und es ist, also wenn sich noch irgendjemand fragt, weil das auch immer aufkommt, wie egocentrisch und sonst was das ist, dass das Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht, Sarah Wagenknecht heißt. Es gibt für Sarah Wagenknecht, also ich will sie nicht verteidigen, ich will nur sagen, es gibt für sie keine andere Möglichkeit. Wenn sie sich jetzt irgendwie nennen würde, BBZ oder was weiß ich ja, dann wäre den meisten in der Wahlurne nicht klar, wen sie wählen sollen. Und dann würden sie sagen, wo waren sie noch mal? Aber deswegen, also es wäre noch besser, es wäre noch ein Bild von ihr mit auf dem Wahlzettel drauf.
Bedeutet aber auch, wir müssen jetzt Hedwig Richter ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen. Sie war gerade überrascht, dass auf ihrem eigenen Buchtitel Revolution steht, wenn es doch schon an Demokratie scheitert. Ja, also, lassen wir ihr das mal durchgehen. Interessanterweise Bürgerrede, da denkt man ja, da werden so Leute in Klausur geschickt und die reden dann miteinander, und zwar mal ohne Moderation und so weiter. Nein, hier ausschließlich Gespräche zwischen Moderation und diesen 100. Alles andere schweigen, man weiß, man ist im Fernsehen, wir niemanden stören gerade bei der Sendung. Also niemand redet mit irgendwem. Die stehen da einfach nur rum in dieser Stunde, bis sie angesprochen werden.
Sagen Sie mal, wieso haben Sie sich hier ganz auf die drei, ganz rausgestellt?
Weil die anderen Parteien genug Zeit hatten, alles richtig zu machen.
Dann soll man den Leuten da auch nicht Chance geben.
Das heißt, Sie sagen, AfD soll mal einfach mal machen?
Genau.
Was würden Sie sich davon erhoffen?
Dass die Sachen, die schon seit Jahren nicht mehr angepackt wurden, angepackt werden.
Zum Beispiel?
Alles Mögliche.
Die Straßen sind kaputt. Von überall wird Geld hingeschickt, nur in Deutschland nicht.
Okay.
Ja, die Radwege in Peru schimmern doch da durch.
Ich meine, du gehst in eine Fernsehsendung und weißt, es könnte sein, dass Sie mich da nach politischen Inhalten fragen. Und dann passiert das ja auch. Und Sie sagen, alles Mögliche.
Ja, aber insofern waren die Sendungen ja tatsächlich aufschlussreich, denn das ist der Diskurs, wie er stattfindet. Genau, alle anderen Leute, die Profis sind, haben ihre Talking Points und wissen, okay, ich kann da so drei Sätze sagen, dann muss das auch knackig kommen. Aber hier ist es einfach so, die sollen wir machen und geht ja eh alles in den Bach runter. Und das reicht eigentlich und so wird ja gewählt. Also so eine Sendung ist natürlich auch ein Schlag ins Gesicht, dass man ein Bürgerat macht. Das ist ja ein Habermasches Modell. Und dann zeigt man jetzt mal, wie das ist, wenn man nicht ein Bürgerat hat, wie das jetzt bei Marlen Engelhorn über viele Wochenenden eingelaitet und begleitet ist, sondern wenn man einfach die Leute dann fragt, dann ist natürlich das sehr dürftig.
Ja, ich würde euch mal zur Ästhetik dieses Bildes noch eine kleine Pointe, von der ich so dachte, das müsste man eigentlich auch nochmal. Diese Frau sieht ja durch Zufall gerade aus, als wäre sie gerade beim Einkaufen oder so. Sie hat nämlich so ein Ding um die Schulter. Sie sieht eigentlich aus wie eine Straßenumfrage. An diesem Kordelding hängt ein iPad. Sie soll also da, wo sie sich hinstellt, auch immer nochmal bestätigen, dass sie da steht, weil es dem Sender irgendwie zu kompliziert ist, kurz auszuzählen, wie viel da steht, sondern die sollen es nochmal digital bestätigen. Ich hätte dann auch im Nachhinein nochmal eine Auswertung gemacht, ob das eigentlich übereinstimmt oder ob wir da so plus minus 30 Prozent über haben. Ich meine, man ruft die Leute zu Hause an und macht so eine dynmoskopische, wie findet sich Sarah Wagenknecht plus minus fünf und so. Ich glaube, nicht mal auf so einem Feld kriegen das ordentlich operationalisiert. Na ja, jedenfalls habe ich mir ja das letzte Mal gewünscht, dass man sich einfach konfrontiert, dass man sagt, okay, sie haben jetzt AfD gewählt, vielleicht haben sie in der Zeitung gelesen, warum wir jetzt den Höcke nicht unbedingt als Ministerpräsidenten tragen könnten und dann einfach sagt, ja, also in Thüringen passiert jetzt nichts, bis sie sich zu irgendwas verhalten haben. Hier passiert nichts, bei dem sie einfach im Nachhinein sagen können, ja, das finde ich aber blöd, sondern sie müssen im Vorfeld mal bei einer Sache und dann nicht, ja, so alles oder so, sondern einer Sache mal erklären, was ist hier eigentlich, was ist ihnen wichtig. So wie Gilda Sahibi ja sagte, auch AfD-Wähler haben rassistische, aber eben auch normale Belange, um die kann man sich ja kümmern. In dieser Sendung fand jetzt auch eine Konfrontation statt. Licht aus.
Sie hier im Dunkeln dürfen jetzt nicht mehr mitspielen. Ich bitte Sie, das Spielfeld zu verlassen.
Einmal bitte alle im Dunkeln das Spielfeld verlassen.
Das sind also jetzt die AfD-Zugehörigen gewesen?
Sind die Spielregeln, die wir hier machen.
Einmal bitte verlassen.
Vertrauen Sie uns.
Das ist Ausgrenzung.
Als ich das hörte, in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit, dachte ich noch, okay, ich verstehe, da wurden gerade, ich höre es ja dann nur, so Leute runtergeschickt. Das ist Ausgrenzung im Sinne von Grenzen zu, wir grenzen jetzt aus. Es ging aber wirklich um die Ausgrenzung der AfD-Wähler. Damit hat man, finde ich, relativ deutlich, aber ohne Reflektion einfach markiert, das ist durchaus ein Problem, die AfD-Wähler auszugrenzen. Also es lief so als relativ manifester, aber Subton einfach mit. Dann kam natürlich die große Stunde Ingo Zamparounis. Er musste ja das dann so ein bisschen erklären und auflösen.
Ja, greifen wir die Frage doch gleich mal auf. Sie sind jetzt quasi des Feldes verwiesen worden. Wie hat sich das angefühlt für Sie?
Komisch.
Ziemlich doof eigentlich.
Ja, ich glaube, ähnlich geht es vielen Wählerinnen und Wählern der AfD, die sagen, Moment, meine Stimme da und die wird jetzt quasi ignoriert.
Ich habe den ganzen Modus hier nicht verstanden, sondern die Sendung geht eine Stunde.
Also die Idee ist jetzt zu sagen, die AfD ist doch auch ein Teil von Deutschland und das können wir ja doch jetzt nicht irgendwie ausgrenzen. Also was natürlich auch impliziert, ein AfD-Verbot ging ja nicht, weil man würde ja dann die Wähler ausgrenzen, wo man einfach sagen könnte, nee, die haben halt das dann nicht mehr als Angebot zum Wählen. Die müssen dann sich irgendwas anderes aussuchen. Irgendwo sagt auch mal jemand, ihr könnt ja die Tierschutzpartei oder die grauen Panter wählen, die machen ja nichts. Ist ja auch ein Angebot.
Ja, also die AfD ist noch niemals von dem Wahlzettel geflogen und erst recht nicht außen im Parlament. Also wenn die gewählt ist, sitzt sie im Parlament. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die ausgrenzen.
Aber demonstriert werden sollte ja jetzt, das ist ganz schlimm, jemanden auszugrenzen und dann sollten jetzt alle wieder singen, ach nee, das Demokratie ist aber auch wieder alle mit ins Boot zu holen.
Genau, wo ich mir dann auch denke, naja, aber eine 30-Prozent-Partei, ja, das ist viel, aber 30-Prozent-Parteien, die es dann nicht in die Regierung schaffen, das ist jetzt nicht ungewöhnlich. Die reden auch nicht mit. Das ist auch nicht ungewöhnlich. Also irgendwo wird da so eine Ausgrenzung aus der Luft, aus dem Diskurs gesogen, den aber die ARD ja selber veranstaltet so. Also es ist ja auch so ein Zirkelschluss, der hier einfach mal durch explizit.
Vor allen Dingen, das gesamte Programm der AfD besteht ja aus Ausgrenzung. Also es ist ja ein reines Programm der Unterscheidungen, jene, die dazugehören und jene, die nicht dazugehören.
Ach du bist unter 40? Ja, wie fühlt es sich so ausgeschlossen? Du musst jetzt Stefan Raab gucken, den 60er.
Also es ist ja, es ist doch völlig verrückt, also dass man das hier so alles miteinander vermischt und dann so ein Punkt kommt wie, ah ja Demokratie muss ja alles sein. Also eigentlich ist das ziemlich genau das, was Herbert Marcuse repressive Toleranz genannt hätte. Also man kann natürlich die Demokratie auch dadurch aussöhlen, indem man einfach immer sagt, ja alles gehört irgendwie auch dazu. Also dann hilft es ja nichts.
Es ist eben, die Fragestellung hier ist, wie fühlen sie sich denn dabei? Es kommen zwar kaum Ausländer nach Deutschland, aber wie fühlen sie sich denn dabei, wenn der eine kommt und ein Messer kauft und zusticht? Das ist natürlich eine völlig berechtigte Frage, dass man jetzt alle 80 Millionen Deutschen plötzlich fragt, wie man sie sich, wie sie sich dabei fühlen oder hier repräsentativ.
Wie hat sich das für Sie angefühlt?
Ich war total überrumpelt, dass ich plötzlich ausgeschlossen wurde.
Ich dachte, ich habe gar nichts falsch gemacht.
Plötzlich muss ich raus.
Sie müssen aber nicht wirklich raus, denn das war nur quasi eine Demonstration, wie sich das anfühlen kann. Deswegen kommen Sie gerne bitte wieder zurück auf die Spielfläche.
Das war natürlich nur ein Spaß. Es ist wirklich verrückt. Die Sendung bestand ansonsten aus O-Tönen, die Ingo eingesammelt hat. Also hier fanden keine Diskussionen statt. Hier war einfach nur, jeder hat kurz durchkalkuliert, ah ja, 100 Leute in 60 Minuten, Moderation abgezogen. Ich habe also, wenn es hochkommt, im Schnitt drei Sekunden Zeit. Und jede Sekunde mehr, die mir gegeben wird, weiß ich, dass es über Nachspielzeit ist, sozusagen. Die nutze ich dann auch. Und so war es dann einfach nur noch so eine O-Ton-Olympiade, die hier abgefeuert wurde?
Ich bin nicht rassistisch und mir ist es auch egal, ob jemand Muslim ist oder Christ, dass ich Flüchtlingen oder in Not stehenden Menschen helfen muss, ist keine Frage der Religion. Das ist selbstverständlich.
Und trotzdem stehen sie sich hier auf die Gegenseite?
Wo ich mich wäre, dass wir überrannt werden von Ausländern, die hier nicht hingehören, die Sozialschmarotzer sind, die nicht arbeiten, die nicht Deutsch lernen. Meine Frau war Lehrerin, die hat in der Schule zu hören bekommen, ich muss kein Deutsch lernen, denn Deutschland gehört uns bald.
Der ist vielleicht auch mit der Frau von Tilo Sachazin verheiratet. Die ist ja auch Lehrerin, die hat ja auch so Geschichten immer erzählt.
Also, was die zu dritter veranstaltet.
Es ist auch so interessant, dass er erst nochmal so diesen ganz großen Toleranzbogen schlägt, um dann einmal zu sagen, die hier nicht hingehören und die uns überrennen. Also das ist interessant, diese Parallelität von dem inklusiven Vokabular mit dem rassistischen Vokabular so gekoppelt, habe ich auch selten in 15 Sekunden gesehen.
Ich frage mich natürlich, wenn man jetzt als AD-Sendung so was veranstaltet und dann kommen diese Leute und äußern sich so und ich habe mir aber eigentlich Gedanken gemacht für meine Sendung und wollte ja irgendwas und ich mache da eine Nachbesprechung und ich frage mich dann, woher kommt die Idee des Überrennens, also hat er Leute auf der Straße rennen gesehen, die irgendwie ihm und so und das Sozialschmarotzertum, woher weiß er das? Er kann das ja nur aus dem Fernsehen wissen.
Wenn man aber ein Sendekonzept hat, das überhaupt keine Nachfrage erlaubt, bleibt es genauso im Raum stehen und 50 Prozent sitzen vom Fernseher und sagen, endlich sagt es mal einer. Und das ist deshalb eigentlich eine große Wahlwerbesendung für die AfD gewesen, würde ich sagen.
Wir hören mal den letzten Clip, da wird das so ein bisschen deutlich, denn man hat jetzt einfach diese 60 Minuten, man füllt sie halt einfach bis zum Schluss, man hat null Idee, also ein Konzept, sieht man ja, ist irgendwie vorhanden, solche Bildschirme müssen ja auch bestellt werden und so, aber man hat absolut keine Idee, außer das Ingo Zamparoni, wie fühlen sie sich?
Was haben Sie?
Wie fühlen sie sich? So geht das durch die Sendung und so steigen die dann aus.
Wo standen Sie zu Beginn der Sendung?
Ich stand auch hier.
Dann haben Sie die Position ja gar nicht so verändert.
Nein, aber ich habe meine Meinung ein wenig geändert.
Nämlich?
Ja, ich meine, ich weiß, dass die AfD extrem ist, aber ich wähle sie trotzdem und das ist Protestwahl. Ich höre auch immer nur, die fremden Menschen haben Angst, es fragt kein Mensch, was wir Einheimischen für Angst haben. Also ich traue mich bei mir zu Hause kommen auf die Straße. Da fragt niemand danach. Es geht nur immer um Migration.
Haben Sie da mal was erlebt auch oder ist das eher gefühlter Angst?
Also nicht direkt, aber es macht mir Angst, wenn wirklich Trauben von Menschen entgegenkommen, auch nicht ausweichen. Wie gesagt, deswegen gehe ich kaum noch auf die Straße.
So, dann gehen wir noch mal hier auf diese Seite.
Und holen uns noch ein paar Urtöne ab.
Ja, ein Offenbarungseid, diese ganze Sendung.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, wir finden ja gut, wenn Empirie vorkommt in Büchern und Sachen und nicht nur Projekte, die ausgedacht werden. Und hier würde ich sagen, hier haben wir doch jetzt die Leute gesehen, die konfrontiert werden müssen. Also es darf keine Regierungsbildung geben, bevor nicht die Leute erklärt haben, was sie jetzt wollen.
Aber da muss man sie konfrontieren und nicht einfach ein paar Gefühle abfragen.
Die Gefühle abfragen ist natürlich so Schritt eins von sieben. Und am Ende muss aber ein konstruktiver Vorschlag, der praktikabel ist. Also man muss sich jetzt mal herauskristallisieren. Aber wenn man denen jetzt einfach wieder so eine Arithmetik mit, ja wir haben jetzt lang genug verhandelt, der Ramelow macht es und das ist der eine, der dann die Mehrheit gibt und so weiter. Thüringen hat endlich wieder eine Mehrheit. Und dann gibt es nur noch eine Opposition, die AfD. Ja, dann wird diese Frau für immer Angst haben vor der Traube von Menschen, die ihn in Limburg greizt gegenüber oder in Limburg. Ich war ja kürzlich in Limburg, also da habe ich keine Traube, da ist nämlich niemand. Du steigst aus dem ICE und denkst schon, ja genau, das musste sehr hart politisch verhandelt werden, dass der ICE hier hält, es macht keinen Sinn. Aber gut.
Jetzt kommen wir zu unserer Inhaltsdebate. Die Inhalte.
Ich habe Wolfgang schon gesagt, dass ich über Inhalte sprechen möchte, denn Wolfgang hat ja Ansprüche angemerkt. Ich habe eine Beobachtung geteilt, du hast Ansprüche angemerkt und diesen Ansprüchen dachte ich, ja, den muss man genügen, denn du hast sie natürlich eloquent und damit intelligent vorgetragen und sie sind durchaus berechtigt.
Man macht das aber tatsächlich dann mit Humor und nicht in so einer Kirsentags-Predigt.
Es gibt so viel Shit-Talking gerade auf YouTube. Es ist wirklich eine Freude.
Nur werden wir irgendwann auch über Inhalte reden müssen und da, warum?
Trump hat auch nicht irgendwann mal über Inhalte reden müssen, um die mal im amokantischen Perspektive zu finden.
Nein, wenn man jetzt aus der kritischen Perspektive heraus Kandidaten beurteilen will.
So, und wir wollen ja aus der kritischen Perspektive heraus.
Das sagten wir im Juli 2024.
Genau. Das war gerade die Zeit nach dem Denominierungsparteitag, aber vor der Debatte. Wir wissen ja heute sehr viel Inhalte, haben wir nicht gesehen. Und wir wollen ja trotzdem eine kritische Würdigung der Kandidaten, denn das ist ja das Einzige, was uns hier interessiert. Welche inhaltliche Relevanz hat es, sowohl wer der amerikanische Präsident oder Präsidentin ist und was bedeutet das als, es gucken ja auch Leute zu, wie dieser Ploss aus Hamburg oder Kassen Linnemann. Kriegen wir die noch mal dazu Inhalte oder ist das jetzt nur noch Gefühlichkeit und so?
Du siehst also schon doch auch ein Problem darin.
Ich sehe da ein sehr großes Problem und ich bringe das Thema nur mit, weil es jetzt eine Lösung gibt. Und ich will dazu sagen, ihr seid ja Kenner des Podcasts, ich will Wolfgang jetzt in eine Zwickmühle bringen. Alternative A oder B. Aber beide sind so ein bisschen angegiftet. Schon wegkommentiert. Leider was sie sehen. Erst mal, bevor wir die Inhalte wieder zurückholen ins Bild, müssen wir sie, also müssen wir wirklich zeigen, wie dramatisch sie aussortiert wurden. Also gucken wir uns noch mal kurz diesen Nominierungsparteitag an.
Soon and very soon, we're going to be teaching our daughters and sons about how this child of an Indian mother and a Jamaican father, two idealistic, energetic immigrants, grew up to become the 47th President of the United States. Let's fight for it. Let's get out there. Let's vote for it.
Ich habe ja im Wintersalon diese Florian Silbereisen-Show mal hier vorgeführt. Da würde ich sagen, es hatte am Ende doch mehr Niveau als dieser Parteitag.
Ja, genau.
Also es ist doch nicht auszuhalten.
Keine Inhalte.
Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, wer mich wütender macht, die auf der Bühne oder dieses hysterische Publikum. Männer, die anfangen zu weinen, wenn Kinder schreien, Mikrofone oder irgendwas.
Es ist das nächste großartige Chapter in der größten Geschichte, die die Menschheit jemals geschrieben hat. Und das Wichtigste, was das Publikum wissen muss, ist, dass sie Kamalala heißt. Das passt doch wunderbar zusammen. Es gibt hier noch kleine punktuelle, die fand ich wirklich auch niedlich.
Wolfgang hat über seine und seine Frau ihre Erfahrung mit Fertilitätsvertätigkeiten gesprochen.
Als unsere Tochter geboren wurde, namen wir sie Hope. Komm schon, Mann.
Also nicht nur die kritischen Beobachter, alle leiden hier so ein bisschen an Inhaltslosigkeit. Und jetzt kriegen wir aber Aufklärung, was es damit auf sich hat. Ab und zu sind ja doch Leute, die man noch nie vorher gesehen hat im Fernsehen und die sieht man auch danach nie wieder. Ich kannte jedenfalls Stefan Bierling nicht. Er hält jetzt den Fernsehleuten mal so richtig die Lampe quasi ins Gesicht. Das fand ich wirklich überraschend, auch aus dem Juli.
Wie sehr ging es da um Emotionen statt Fakten?
Emotionen sind ein ganz zentraler Teil der Politik. Das hat uns Donald Trump beigebracht. Er hat uns viel beigebracht, wie Politik funktioniert. Er hat die Vernunft mehr oder weniger ausgesetzt vor neun Jahren, als er diesen Eskalator runterfuhr in seinem Trump Tower und auf Einwanderer zu schimpfen begann.
So, die kritischen Beobachter, denen fehlen Inhalte. Die Comedians missen keine Inhalte. Jetzt kommen die Wissenschaftler und sagen, ja genau, so ist es halt. Die Moderatorin hier vom Tagesthema fragt nochmal, ja und so weiter. Es gibt doch auch so Wahlprogramme, oder? Kann man das nicht mal lesen?
Aber Kamala Harris ist politisch wenig konkret geworden, teilweise sogar widersprüchlich und am Ende wurde sogar ein Wahlprogramm verabschiedet, in dem an verschiedenen Stellen noch von einer zweiten Amtszeit Joe Bidens die Rede ist. Kommt man damit durch?
Ja, das spielt keine wirklich große Rolle. Dieses Wahlprogramm liest sowieso niemand. Und ob man jetzt konkreter wird, in manchen Punkten ist nicht so entscheidend. Wichtig bei diesem Wahlparteitag war diese Lethargie, dieses Siechtum, das wir ja bis vor vier Wochen mit der Kandidatur von Joe Biden erlebt haben, zu überwinden.
Ich befürchte, dass er absolut recht hat. Ich will die Diagnose nicht in Zweifel stellen.
Ich wollte dich auch gerade fragen, wie fühlst du dich dabei, wenn du sowas...
Du bist bestätigt.
Ja. Die ARD gibt sich hier mal geschlagen. Während wir bisher noch hofften, dass die Unterscheidung war Emotion und Fakten. Und irgendwer noch mal insichtlich Fakten abbiegt, sagt man hier einfach ganz deutlich, es geht nur noch Emotion gegen Emotion.
Experten beobachten, die Demokraten haben sich einen neuen Umgang mit dem politischen Gegner verordnet. Weg von der Dämonisierung hin zur Lächerlichkeit. Es ist nicht mehr, oh, sie haben diese schlimmen Ansichten, sie werden uns schaden. Das ist viel zu abstrakt. Es ist eher, sie sind uncool. Niemand, mit dem man abhängen möchte.
Ja, es gibt nur noch gute Laune, schlechte Laune, weird, normal, wie auch immer. Aber Fakten, bis hierhin aussortiert. Jetzt gucke ich natürlich nicht nur Tagesthemen, wir hören ja auch viele Podcasts. Ich will mal den Rundown weitermachen, um uns den letzten Hoffnung nehmen, dass irgendwer Inhalte erwartet. Niemand erwartet mehr Inhalte. So wie der Politikwissenschaftler gerade meinte, ne, das hat uns Trump doch gelehrt. Er war der größte Lehrer uns Politikwissenschaftler. Er hat uns einfach gesagt, ne, ne, es spielt alles keine Rolle, was ihr da macht und so. Man muss nicht nur die neoliberale Ökonomie, wie es an der Uni einmal aussortieren, sondern eigentlich müsste man auch diesen ganzen politischen Reflektionsbetrieb einmal entkernen. Wir fangen mal an bei der New York Times. Hier kommt es nicht nur drauf an, dass es der größte Podcast der Welt ist. Also ab und zu mal ist es nur Platz zwei. Aber in dieser The Daily Podcast, der wird ja nun wirklich überall gehört. Es ist ein politischer Podcast. Wir erwarten da Informationen über die Welt. Stattdessen, sie machen sich geradezu lustig darüber, dass irgendwer noch auf Inhalte wartet.
Wir wissen nicht, was für ein Präsident sie sein wird. Wir wissen nicht, was die Stimme eines Kamala-Harris-demokratischen Partys aussehen würde und wie das von dem, den Biden ausgesprochen hat, anders sein würde. Aber ehrlich gesagt, wenn du einen Demokraten fragst, sagen sie, das ist das Problem von morgen. Und so lange sie die Wahl gewinnen und Donald Trump von einem anderen Termin stoppt.
Das wäre ja dann schon der Blick, der interessant wäre, für Journalisten aufzubereiten. Also dass das bei den meisten Wählern so geht, das will ich ja jeden Moment glauben. Nur die Sache ist ja, wenn man nicht mehr erwartet, außer lustige Liedchen zu singen oder so.
Dann müssen wir jetzt ganz fein unterscheiden zwischen dem politischen Betrieb und der Demokratie, den wir als Mantel außenrum gebaut haben. Der politische Betrieb braucht natürlich Inhalte. Also da sitzen Verwaltungsbeamte, die schreiben Programme, die werden genehmigt, da werden Budgets zugeteilt und so weiter. Nur hat das noch einen Zusammenhang mit dem demokratischen Mantel für uns?
Wir haben doch den Crazy Rich gesehen, dass dann ein bisschen Lobbyarbeit reicht, damit dann Politiker zum Beispiel aus der CSU sagen, ach so, die wollen weiterhin erbschaftssteuerfrei ihre Riesenkonglomerate verehrten. Ja, machen wir doch. Also da gibt es ja erstmal von der Politik das, was dann umgesetzt werden muss von der Verwaltung.
Genau. Also in Deutschland gibt es 60 Millionen Wähler. Und wenn man einen politischen Erfolg haben will, muss man Lobbyismus kaufen. Und wenn der 60 Millionen kostet für ein Projekt, ist das schon sehr viel. Das ist ein Euro pro Wähler. Und damit hat man einfach dieses Ding schachmattgesetzt. Niemand wartet irgendwo auf irgendeine inhaltliche Diskussion. Der politische Betrieb, inklusive Lobby, macht halt einfach, was er macht.
Und du würdest das so fatalistisch sehen, denn die Sache ist ja, Trump hat uns jetzt was gezeigt. Aber Trump ist ja auch schon aus einem gewissen Umfeld herausgekommen. Was ich sagen will, ist, diese postdemokratischen Zustände, die wir hatten, so kann man sie wohl nennen, haben ja auch dazu geführt, dass man eine große Gruppe von Leuten hat, die politisch eigentlich desinteressiert sind, sich aber durch so eine plumpe Emotionalisierung locken lassen, wie das ja auch jetzt geschieht, dass dann Heino sagt, naja, aber ich will jetzt schon nochmal was gegen Ausländer hier gesagt haben.
Ja, also ich löse meine Pointe natürlich gleich erst auf. Denn ich sehe ja einen Rückweg zu den Inhalten. Nur sind es die traditionellen mehr Bildung, mehr irgendwas, mehr Aufmerksamkeit, noch mehr Talks. Also ich will mal daran erinnern, in Österreich, wo wir seit mehreren Wahlperioden, und wir sehen das dann in einem Monat, glaube ich, wieder bei der Nationalratswahl, FPÖ, ÖVP mit verfassungsgebenden Mehrheiten haben, finden pro Wahl mehr als 50 TV-Duelle statt zwischen den Kandidaten aller Parteien. Also mehr Tod quatschen kann man das gar nicht, wenn man sich jetzt in Deutschland denkt, ja, wir sollten einfach mehr darüber reden oder so. Dieses österreichische Modell ist vielleicht nicht so das Richtige. So und das, was ich hier zeige, ist ja nicht, irgendwer hat irgendwelche Wünsche, sondern die beschreiben Zustände. In der New York Times haben wir gerade eine Zustands-, eine gegenwärtige Zustandsbeschreibung gehört. Jetzt hören wir hier David Axelrod. Wir kennen ihn als eigentlich immer Verwaltungschef von allem, sei es der Obama-Wahlkampf oder dann Chief Advisor oder wie das dann heißt, da im politischen Betrieb, der auch mal eine Beobachtung schildert.
Präsidential Politik, besonders an diesem Punkt in einer Kampagne, ist so viel gewohnt durch das Moment-zu-Moment-Behavior der Kandidaten, was die Leute immer sehen. Ich meine, sie sind unter Konzentration. Und die Leute bewegen sich auf das, was sie in der Realität sehen, sogar wenn sie mit Advertisungen bombardiert werden. Sie sieht nichts wie die Karikature, die sie auf ihr schlagen.
Sie sind selber da aufgebaut. Also hat ja Obama auch in diese Richtung getränkt. Der Präsident fährt Auto und so. Ja, solche Sachen. Journalisten fahren mit dem Präsidenten Auto. Der Präsident sitzt am Steuer. Das hat man ja noch nie gesehen. Neue Sehngewohnheiten gibt es auch zu vermelden. Hier bei Kara Swisher am Podcast.
Wir sind jetzt neun Jahre in der Trump-Szene-Ära. Und wir sind so unglücklich, dass die Idee, dass ein Typ, der normal und nett ist, durchdreht, das ist, wie desprit wir für das sind.
Ja, wenn das Novum ist, dass sich jemand wieder normal verhält, wo doch vorher Missachtung, Deviance, Attraktion, Trump, der große Unterhalter. Ne, jetzt geht man einfach als Tim Walz halt zum Football. Fertig. Das ist das Argument.
Und man sollte das auch nicht unterschätzen, dass das Showbusiness auch genau von dieser Normalität lebt. Es ist nicht nur das Extravagante. Es ist nicht nur Lady Gaga im Fleischkostüm oder Taylor Swift auf ihrer Stadion-Tournee. Und es ist auch nicht früher nur Liberace im Glitzeranzug gewesen, sondern wenn man mal schaut, wer ist eigentlich populär, gerade im deutschen Fernsehen, dann haben wir da jemanden wie Günter Jauch. Das ist so in Anführungszeichen der normalste Deutsche, den man sich überhaupt vorstellen könnte. Und der ist wahnsinnig beliebt und seit Jahren im Geschäft. Ähnlich auch andere Moderatoren, auch Harpel Kerkeling, hat zwar ein paar verrückte Rollen, verkörpert aber diese Normalität. Oder dann gibt es natürlich auch die ewigen Langweiler, die komischerweise aber immer da sind, so Matthias Optenhöfel, oder wie der heißt. Wo man auch nicht einen Satz zu sagen könnte, eine Charaktereigenschaft finden könnte, aber trotzdem immer auf Sendung. Das heißt, dieser Wunsch, in der Show auch Normalität zu sehen, scheint relativ groß zu sein.
Ja, es gibt bei YouTube und der Influencern, wie ich derzeit sehe, kein beliebteres Genre als Day in a Life of. Und dann geht man halt einmal den Alltag so durch.
Ja, wir haben das ja im Sommersalon so angesprochen, dass die einfach so kurz Revue passieren lassen. Es ist nichts Tolles passiert.
Das kommt dazu.
Und morgen sehen wir uns dann auch wieder. Und dann passiert aber auch nichts Besonderes.
Hier, Podsave America, das sind die ehemaligen Rednerschreiber von Barack Obama, die hier mal den Parteitag einschätzen. Aus der Sicht, den letzten Parteitag haben wir ja mitveranstaltet und organisiert und jetzt sehen wir Zuschauer. Was gefällt uns eigentlich nicht?
Die Leute sprechen zu verdammt langsam.
Und ich weiß nicht, was ich zu beantworten tun soll.
Ich habe das schon mal gesagt.
Ich kann nicht aufhören, darüber zu reden. Wenn du es siehst, kannst du nicht aufhören.
Das ist so langweilig im Fernsehen. Das kommt bei der TikTok-Sägewohnheit nicht entgegen. Die Leute werden so nicht abgeholt. Da ist zu wenig Transport der Stimmung aus dem Saal nach Hause. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich glaube das ist ja gar nicht so richtig. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob so viele junge Leute wirklich so sind, nur weil sie sehr viel TikTok konsumieren. Ich will ein Gegenbeispiel bringen, weil ich eben noch mal daran erinnernt wurde. Hier ist nämlich ein Lehrer zugangs, der mich eingeladen hatte in seine Schule. Und wie alt waren die da? Das war so eine 10. Klasse, etwa 10. oder 11. Klasse. Ja, 10. oder 11. Klasse. Und ich kam dort an, sollte einen Vortrag über Influencer halten, dachte, naja, wie werde ich das wohl machen können? Ich kann ja jetzt nicht 60 Minuten sprechen, nonstop ein Monolog halten. Und dann sagte man mir nicht 60 Minuten, sondern 90 Minuten. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, das soll gut gehen. Und das ging gut. Wir saßen sehr aufmerksam da. Niemand holte ein Smartphone raus. Alle waren gebannt und haben danach dann kluge Fragen gestellt.
Das ist auch sehr gut.
Das gibt es auch.
Dass du jetzt die Wählergruppe nennst, die noch nicht wählen darf und deren Wahlrecht ich dir mühsam eingeprügelt habe. Das ist überhaupt eine relevante Geschichte.
Ja, die hätte man noch alle wählen lassen können. Definitiv. Nur will ich damit sagen, die kennen auch kurze Clips sicherlich, aber trotzdem können die auch 90 Minuten aushalten.
Ja, weil die halt noch in die Schule gehen. Die haben ja noch andere Sehgewohnheiten, weil sie staatlich verpflichtet der Schule ausgesetzt sind. So, hier haben wir John Stewart. Wir kennen ihn, The Daily Show. Der hat allerdings auch seinen eigenen Podcast und erklärt hier nochmal Parteitage.
Hmm. Das sind keine politischen Konventionen mehr.
Und ich würde es gerne für Sie geben, um ein bisschen zu verstehen, wie das Ganze entwickelt wurde.
Sie denken an Konventionen in einem politischen Sinne, die konstitutionelle Konvention. Ein Begrüßungsverhältnis der Leader und der Eliten, für wenige negativ oder positiv du das sehen willst, die sich hinsetzen und die Philosophie unserer Begrüßungsprinzipien aufbauen, wie wir vorwärts gehen. Und jetzt, über diese Jahre, hat es sich in der Art von Konventionen entwickelt, wie eine Zeitzeitkonvention.
Wie ein Thema ausgesprochen ist. Ist es die größte Geschichte ever? Ja, muss man irgendwas dazu wissen? Nein. Und dann geht man das halt so durch. Letzte Stimme, die wir hier hören, ist Mike Murphy. Der macht mit David Axelrod zusammen den Podcast. Also Axelrod, wie gesagt, Obamas großer Held. Mike Murphy, die Gegenposition vor Trump-Zeitalter. Also er hat immer die Präsidentschaftskandidaten sozusagen gegen Axelrod, also damals, was weiß ich, wie sie alle hießen, hier mit Romney und so. Gekocht und die Wahlkämpfe organisiert. Und die beiden haben durch das Trump-Zeitalter einen gemeinsamen Podcast, Hex on Tap, in dem die eben besprechen. Also wir hören jetzt auch aus der sozusagen wirklichen Zuschauerrolle. Also hier redet ein Republikaner über den Demokratenparteitag und zieht nochmal die Schlüsse.
By the way, this is an important convention, I think, for convention historians like you guys. It is the ultimate finish of the big turn, because now it's totally a TV show. Even the roll call vote is meaningless. They are doing a fake roll call vote to create the TV show of a roll call vote. It was really done by a conference call a couple of weeks ago.
Ja, weil in einem Bundesstaat in Amerika die Stimmen schon vorher auf dem Wahlzettel landen mussten, hat man einfach per Telefonschalte die delegierten Stimmen aus allen Staaten zusammengesammelt, hatte die schon zusammen und hat dann eine Woche später den Parteitag veranstaltet, wo selbst das Einsammeln, da werden dann die Staaten einzeln aufgerufen, die erklären dann, da gab es ja dann auch kleine Pop-Einlagen und so. Selbst das war nur noch Show. Es war ja formal alles schon geregelt.
Was ja auch dazu passt, dass man in der Primetime für gewöhnlich das Beste anbieten will. Und eigentlich wäre in der Primetime auch beiden dran gewesen mit seiner Rede. Und man hat es aber geschafft, das immer weiter zu verzögern, zu verzögern, hat also andere Inhalte, die besser gehen, geliefert. Beiden wurde unruhig, auch wohl sehr sauer hinter der Bühne. Und dann hat man ihn erst ins späte Programm gesetzt, so wie man es heute mit der Kultur im Fernsehen macht.
Ja, also John hier, Dings hat sich ja sehr drüber lustig gemacht, dass sie ein Vize-Gouverneur nach dem anderen noch auf der Rednerliste haben, bevor dann irgendwann 22.30 Uhr oder so, als alle schon im Bett waren, beiden nochmal reden durfte. Also was ist das jetzt? Wir haben eine überdimensionierte mediale Beschallung, aber keine Inhalte mehr. Wie kommen wir jetzt da wieder raus? Und jetzt kommt meine Zwickmühle.
Kommt jetzt irgendwas mit JCPT und Claude?
Der einzige Weg raus, der sich derzeit nach wissenschaftlich ordentlichen Standards ermitteln ließ, ist tatsächlich, es mit JCPT zu versuchen.
Okay, dann doch lieber keine Inhalte.
Aber es ist trotzdem eine interessante Studie. Selbst Mincorrect hat sie aufgegriffen, letzte Woche habe ich gehört. Wir gehen das mal durch. Also es gab die Reduzierung von Glauben an Verschwörungstheorien nach Nutzung von JCPT in spezifischer Weise. Was ja bedeutet, wenn man den Leuten sogar Verschwörungsglauben dimmen kann, dann haben wir beim politischen Denken so eine Einflugsschneise gefunden. Die Frage ist, was ist das denn für eine? Welchen Mechanismen wirken denn hier?
Das ist also eine Studie, die in Science veröffentlicht wurde. Und das ist eine kommunikationswissenschaftliche IT-Studie? Oder wie hat man das gemacht?
Wir können das als politikwissenschaftliche Studie werten, die sich der Technik verschrieben hat, aber eben so weit operationalisiert, wo man noch nicht so genau weiß, wie werden jetzt genau Forschungssachen, die so hoch individuell sind. Hier gibt es ja nicht einen Fragebogen, eine Auswertung, sondern jedes einzelne empirische Gespräch. Wir haben ja mehrere tausend Leute in solche kleinen Talks geschickt. Das ist ganz interessant, weil sie dann doch relativ viel mit veröffentlicht haben. Man kann teilweise diese Gespräche, die da liefen, einfach nachlesen, in den Datensätzen. Das ist ganz interessant. Es ist auch methodisch interessant, wie man das jetzt... Es ist wirklich interessant, wir haben jetzt hier Operationalisierung, die wirklich sagen, wir können keine Laborsituation herstellen. Nicht nur die Realität, die wir ansonsten abstrahieren, ist einmalig, sondern auch unsere Abstraktion, unsere Operationalisierung ist immer einmalig. Wir können nichts hiervon reproduzieren. Deswegen gehen wir es mal so durch. Also die These ist Wolfgangsthese. Mit Tiefe, inhaltlicher Tiefe, kommt man doch vorwärts bei Verschwörungsglaube. Wir haben hier einen Forschungsstand, den kennen wir soweit. Katharina Nockon und so hat ja die Bücher geschrieben mit B. Eigentlich haben wir jetzt zuletzt immer so gesagt, die Leute, die so Verschwörungsglauben haben, die haben eigentlich so soziale Bedürfnisse. Die suchen eine Gesellschaft, eine Gemeinschaft. Die wollen ihre Angst irgendwie kompensieren, wie auch immer.
Die wollen wieder was glauben.
Genau. Und eigentlich sollten wir da anschließen. Also nicht jemanden die Mondlandungs- fantasien austreiben, sondern du hast offenbar Probleme, keine Ahnung, auf dieser Beziehungsebene da irgendwie rumdoktern. Und die sagen jetzt hier, ne, wir machen das mal nicht. Wir gehen mal nicht diesen Weg. Sondern wir wollen ja zurück zu den Inhalten. Also haben sie es dann auch entsprechend operationalisiert. 2:190 Amerikaner wurden in dieses Gespräch mit GPT geschickt und sollten am Anfang in eigenen Worten ihre Verschwörungstheorie an die sie glauben beschreiben. Es musste nicht zwingend eine Verschwörungstheorie sein. Jeder hat da in dem Falle wirklich seinen eigenen Wortlaut als ursächlichen Prompt für alles, was dann kommt, reingegeben. Was eben bedeutet, hier steht niemand oberlehrerhaft daneben und sagt, die Mondlandung hat auch stattgefunden und so weiter. Sondern nein, die Leute sollen beschreiben, was sie glauben, wovon sie überzeugt sind. Es wird auch nachgefragt, warum bist du denn davon überzeugt und so. Und dann führt man das richtig aus und das ist der Ausgangspunkt. Das ist der innerliche Ausgangspunkt. Also ein, nicht nur eben, haben wir ja auf der Folie vorher gesehen, individueller und tiefer, sondern eben ein, also nicht nur inhaltlich tief, sondern auch personalisiert. Jeder kriegt ja seine eigene Therapie. Ist ein bisschen wie die Neuen Krebstherapie. Das gibt so eine Idee und dann wird aber das Medikament so richtig hergestellt. Sie gehen ja dieser These nach, dass es für Kaninchenlöcher also einen Ausweg gibt. Sie sind keine Einbahnstraße und die Erfolge, die hier ermittelt wurden, zeigen, dass ein Verschwörungsglaube nachhaltig, also über zwei Monate, wahrscheinlich hat das so mit diesem Zeitpunkt der Publikation zu tun. Ist ein bisschen wie bei der Heinsberg-Studie. Wenn Leute nach Studienende sterben, kommen die nicht mehr in die Statistik. Und dann drei Jahre später wurde dann kritisiert, dass die Studie, weil die sind doch gestorben, aber es war halt vorher cut. Also man ist auf diese zwei Monate gegangen und hat gesagt, man konnte den Ideen austreiben, je nach operationalisierung, sagen wir mal jetzt um 20 Prozent, konnte die Intensität dieses politischen Glaubens gedimmt werden, und zwar nachhaltig überzeiten.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal nachfragen. Das heißt, diese Leute kommunizierten mit Chet-GPT. Zunächst mal war der ideologische Standpunkt oder die Ideosynchrosie, wurde genannt, glaube daran, dass das mit dem Mond ganz anders gelaufen ist oder so was. Und dann gibt es eine Kommunikation mit Chet-GPT. Und das sorgt dann am Ende dafür, dass diese Intensität des Verschwörungsglaubens um 20 Prozent gedimmt wird. Das leuchtet mir insofern ein, als Chet-GPT und auch die ganzen anderen KIs ja doch wie neutrale Instanzen auftreten. Zwar gab es immer so Debatten, sind die zu vogue oder sind die sonst irgendwas, aber eigentlich ist diese Neutralität, die da vorgespielt wird, doch etwas, was sehr, sehr leicht verfängt, was ja auch Probleme mit sich bringt. Also ich weiß, als Chet-GPT rauskam, habe ich das mal so auf Thema Schulden, Schuldenbremse und sowas abgeklopft. Und dann bekam man doch so einen gewissen ordo-liberalen Bias da drin und merkte dann, naja, so neutral ist das ja offenbar gar nicht. Aber wo wir es natürlich mit solchen Extremen zu tun haben, also wo Leute sagen, ja, die Erde ist aber eigentlich eine Scheibe und die trinken alle Kinderblut oder so, da ist natürlich nicht mehr neutral. Da ist sozusagen auch das, was vielleicht eine kleine politische Richtung in die eine oder andere Seite hat, nicht entscheidend, sondern das dimmt das generell schon mal runter.
Ja, wir können ja den Kontrast hier richtig aufmachen.
Wenn ich jetzt TGPT frage, sollen wir ganz auf Golddeckung zurückgehen und den Euro abschaffen, dann würde ich natürlich nicht eine Antwort bekommen, die in diese Richtung geht, sondern dann würde man vermutlich eine neutrale, eher orto-liberale Antwort bekommen, die aber dann bei mir diese verrückte Idee ein bisschen dimmt.
Genau, dieser Neutralitätsgedanke, der ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, denn wir können hier mal den Kontrast aufmachen zwischen Ingo Zamparonis Problembehandlung und wie GPT das macht. Ingo Zamparoni zerrt die Leute ins Fernsehen und sagt, ich stelle dir jetzt eine Frage, aber du redest nicht nur mit mir, sondern vor ganz Deutschland. Diese Leute verfallen natürlich total in ihren, meine Identitätsfrage, meine Integritätsfrage, ich muss jetzt hier mich selbst behaupten, ich kann jetzt hier nicht als Pudding vom Feld gehen, mich geschlagen geben, wie auch immer. Also eigentlich hat Ingo Zamparoni das Problem noch verschärft. Er hat noch besonderen sozialen Fokus auf eine Devianz gelegt, die aber identitätsstiftend ist, die er ihm austreiben will. Also müsste er ihn jetzt nicht nur inhaltlich irgendeinen Glaube austreiben, wie, nein, dieser Menschentrauber wird dich nicht zusammenschlagen oder wie auch immer, sondern er muss noch alle Identifikationsmomente, die da drinstecken, auch ausräumen. Also eigentlich hätte er die ganze Persönlichkeit so abräumen müssen vor dem Fernsehen, was natürlich umso schlechter gelingt, umso größer das Publikum ist.
Und hier begegnet man ja nur etwas Abstraktem der KI.
Hier begegnet man gar keine Menschen.
Man hat nur Interaktionen. Es ist so erstaunlich, denn wir haben ja diese Vertrauensfragen immer. Wir haben ja oft da auch über Luhmann gesprochen, der das Vertrauen als so wichtig erachtet. Ich glaube, dieses Vertrauen direkt in einen Menschen spielt da eine große Rolle, wo es direkt um mich und meinen Körper geht. Also auch wenn mittlerweile viele sagen, dass KIs besser in der Diagnose sind bei der Erkennung von Krankheiten, ist zumindest bei mir und ich glaube bei den meisten das noch so, mag zwar sein, dass das im Durchschnitt bei Ärzten eigentlich viel schlechter ist in der Quote, aber dem vertraue ich doch, dem einen da, dem ich gegenüber sitze, und der auch aussieht wie eine Arzt und sich so verhält. Und ja, da ist das Performativ plötzlich so wichtig. Hier aber, wo es so um abstrakte Theorien gehen, wie Erdesflach oder sowas, da will man eigentlich auch ein abstraktes Gegenüber haben, das sagt, naja, so ist es folgendermaßen.
Genau, also wir sehen jetzt hier unten diese kleinen Streifen, sind mal so Standardverschwörungstheorien. Präsidenten werden erschossen, Mond wertbesiedelt und so weiter was. Jeffrey Epstein ist hier dabei. Diese kleinen roten Balken hier oben, die man sieht, sind also die Nachbefragung. Man hat diesen Ausgangspunkt, blau, die beschreiben, an was sie glauben und danach, woran sie glauben. Und da gibt es eine Lücke, die Leute glauben da an weniger. Hier ist also Ausgangspunkt eine inhaltliche These, irgendetwas fand nicht statt. Und dann wird aber an den Argumenten, nur an den Argumenten rumgedoktert. Und niemand verliert sein Gesicht, wenn er hier einfach GPT sagt, er macht irgendwie Sinn, klingt logisch. Weil man weiß, und das ist ja ganz interessant, die haben halt in dem Paper dann so geschrieben, wir haben den Leuten aber gesagt, dass sie mit GPT reden und nicht mit einem Menschen. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist der Grund, warum das gelingt. Weil die Leute wirklich wussten, sie reden hier mit GPT. Sie verlieren hier nicht ihr Gesicht, wenn sie dann schreiben, ja, okay, finde ich irgendwie interessant und so. Weil allen höchstens vor sich selber verlieren sich das Gesicht. Das könnte noch so eine letzte Hürde sein, das müsste man nochmal, das wäre dann so eine deutsche Fragestellung, wie da noch so Verquickungen stattfinden. Also man hat dieses große Dimmen über die Themen hinweg. Plus man hat auch eine Verhaltensänderung. Denn da, wo die anderen Thesen auftauchen, ist man dann seltener zugegen oder lehnt sie mehr ab. Also Social Media Accounts werden dann schon mal aussortiert. Und hier würde ich sagen, wir müssen im Auge behalten. Dieses Experiment wurde mit Leuten gemacht, die in Fernsehsendungen gehen und sich bei der allerersten und wichtigsten Frage auf die falsche Seite stellen und das dann plötzlich feststellen, wenn der Moderator kommt und sagt, wieso stehen sie jetzt hier? Das ist der Ausgangspunkt. Da denke ich mir, wenn man denen irgendwas mal argumentativ sagt, dann hören die überhaupt alle erste Mal überhaupt abweichende Logiken und finden die dann halt schlüssig. Also eigentlich ist es gar nicht so kompliziert, diese Einflugsschneise zu wählen. Nur, man hatte halt keinen Zugang. Weil bisher war ja die Informationsvermittlung immer an einen Gegenüber geknüpft, den man sich gegenüber in Interaktion behaupten muss. So und das scheint dann doch einer der größten Stolpersteine zu sein. Also hier kann man das einmal so am Stück lesen. Beweise und Argumente sind hilfreich. Man muss sich nicht nur an diesen sozialen und psychologischen Bedürfnissen ansetzen. Also wir können dieses Fake-Facts, der Ansatz ist zwar richtig und gut, aber den kann man hier durchaus jetzt mit einer Alternative begegnen. Analytisches Denken hat also durchaus eine Chance, sagen sie ausdrücklich. Die besseren oder sagen wir mal aufgeklärteren, akademisch unterfütterbaren Inhalte haben durchaus eine Chance, wenn man sie entsprechend vermittelt. Und Menschen sind im Allgemeinen bereit, ihre Überzeugung zu aktualisieren, wenn ihnen überzeugende Gegenbeweise vorgelegt werden, eben auf überzeugende Art und Weise, die jetzt nicht noch mal tropidiert wird durch soziale Taktgefühl, Gesichtswahrung und so weiter und so fort.
Ja oder so ein aufdringlicher Ton. Also ich habe ja auch während Corona gesagt, ich ertrache es nicht mehr, dass man mit mir redet, als sei ich sieben Jahre alt, dann bock ich ja irgendwann und sage, ne.
Also wenn GPT ein was nicht hat, ist das ein appellativen Ton. Sondern das kommt ja nun sehr sachte darüber und entschuldigt sich die ganze Zeit. Also wir haben es hier mit interessanten Erkenntnissen zu tun. Entlarvung von Verschwörungstheorien ist also durchaus möglich.
Dann sind die Inhalte also wieder zurück.
Die Inhalte sind zurück. Wenn man eben die bisherigen Herausforderungen, denen man sich stellte, da ran zu gehen, große Fernsehshow, große inhaltliche Aufklärung, großes Theater, heute lagen wir es alle ein.
Wir setzen alle Leute vor GCPT und dann unterhalten die sich da?
Also ich schlage vor, wenn wir die überraschend optimistischen Bilder des neuen politischen Denkens ernten wollen, das ist deine Zwickmühle, dann ist der Weg GCPT oder Clot.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, denn es gibt ja vielleicht auch eine Ansprache, die funktioniert auch jenseits der maschinellen Ansprache. Also ich glaube, dass die Ansprachen häufig falsch waren und sicherlich wird es auch bei sehr Verboten erstmal funktionieren, nicht mit Menschen zu reden. Zugleich aber gibt es ja gerade auch von denjenigen, die beraten, zum Beispiel Leute beraten, die in der Verwandtschaft richtige Verschwörungstheoretik haben, dass man auf so einer zwischenmenschlichen Ebene die daraus bringen kann. Also nicht, indem man die ganze Zeit sie konfrontiert, sondern dass man zeigt, dass man es eigentlich gut mit ihnen meint und offenbar auch noch nicht gechipt ist, weil man sich ja doch ein bisschen zu nett verhält. Und dass das also auch was sein kann. Und ich glaube auch nach wie vor daran, auch wenn das jetzt Kamala Harris vielleicht auch einfach nicht vermag. Also ich finde jetzt auch nicht, dass sie eine tolle Rednerin ist und auch sie gibt keine interessanten Interviews. Sie ist auch keine Frau der Inhalte.
Das macht sie so unangreifbar.
Ja, das mag ja sein. Ich glaube nur, jede findet seine Art dann im politischen Betrieb. Also Redseligkeit ist die Sache von Olaf Scholz nicht, wie wir sehen. Also macht er es nicht. Andere können relativ viel und gut reden. Gregor Gisi, der hat sich dann irgendwann entschieden, nur noch zu reden. Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen viel. Aber generell glaube ich, dass eine Ansprache schon auch noch funktionieren kann. Also über das Chet-Chet-Bit-T hinaus. Ich glaube aber, dass diese Abstraktion, die es hat, dass das eine dimmende Wirkung hat von diesen intensiven Verschwörungsglauben, dass das tatsächlich nicht zu leugnen ist.
Wir kennen ja unsere Plädoyers. Ich will ja nicht die persönliche Ansprache austreiben als Idee. Das ist natürlich eine sehr romantische Idee. Aber ich will noch mal sagen, Aber diese Studie nimmt ganz spezifisch, ist sie als Alternative zu diesem Gedanken.
Ja, ich lasse sie gelten. Also ich bin da gar nicht dagegen. Und das scheint mir das erste Mal zu sein, dass Chatchi BT wirklich sinnvoll ist. Hört, hört. Denn das will ich noch mal gerade hier einfügen. Wir haben jetzt viel über AI in diesem Podcast geredet, aber ich kann ehrlich gesagt in meinem Alltag noch nicht eine einzige Verbesserung finden, außer dass ich schon mal sage, ja, ich finde über Perplexity besser einen Artikel als über die Google-Suche. Aber sonst würde ich sagen, sind die Erträge noch relativ gering? Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob das sich in den nächsten Jahren noch bessert, aber ob wir hier nicht nach großen Blase auf den Leim gehen.
Aber ich habe gerade einen Punkt damit gemacht.
Ja, ja, ja.
In dem ich, Claude hat mir die Studie vorlesen lassen.
Prima. Aber man kann die Studie auch noch selbst lesen. Also das macht ja auch viel Vergnügen vielleicht.
Ich habe natürlich selbst gelesen.
Ich will noch mal eine andere Ansprache hier in Gang setzen. Und zwar, als du mir angekündigt hast, es geht um Inhalte, und dann dachte ich schon, oh Gott, was wird da sein? Da fiel mir ein Gespräch wieder ein. Roger Wilhelmsen war mal in den Sternenstunden der Philosophie bei Roger de Weck zu Gast und erzählt folgende Anekdote. Also wir sind jetzt hier Anfang der Nuller Jahre. Ach, Entschuldigung, jetzt schon einst zu weit gesprungen.
Ich hielt vor einiger Zeit einen Vortrag bei Bertelsmann, wo zufälligerweise ein paar Bertelsmann-Chefs international da waren.
Bertelsmann, der große Buch- und Medienhaus.
Größte Medienkonzern der Welt. Und das war eine Kritik des Fernsehens, die ich dort vortragen durfte. Danach wurde im Garten des damaligen Geschäfts von Bertelsmann Thomas Middelhoff mir ein Herr vorgestellt, der geholfen hatte, den Microsoft-Konzern zu zerschlagen. Nennen wir ihn Mr. Jones. Ich habe seinen Namen vergessen.
Aber Microsoft gibt es doch noch.
Ja, aber sie sind durch eine schwere Krise gegangen, die auf juristischem Wege den Konzern zumindest in Teilen parzelliert hat. Dieser Mr. Jones wird von Herrn Middelhoff gefragt, haben Sie gehört, was er gesagt hat? Ich übersetze es rasch. Da sagt Mr. Jones, nein, leider, ich habe es verpasst. Worum ging es? Daraufhin sagt Middelhoff, es ging um Inhalt. Und daraufhin wendet sich Mr. Jones mit einem Strahlen zu mir und sagt, und sind Sie dafür oder dagegen?
Dass es Inhalte gibt.
Und alles lachte und ich sagte, oh, ich bin dafür. Und er sagte, oh, shame on you. Und alles lachte und keiner hatte einen Grund zu lachen.
Also die Rückkehr von Stefan Raab im Fernsehen. Wir haben das heute laufen lassen im Vollbild. So und dann habe ich immer mal unten geguckt, wie lange läuft denn das eigentlich gerade? 18 Minuten, 32 Minuten. Außer Memes, also er hat irgendwelche Influencer im Internet gesehen und Jürgen Mitzkies Auge und so. Keine Inhalte. Also es ist ganz erstaunlich, keine Inhalte.
Ja, man kann sich das ja ansehen. Roger Wilmsen war ja zweimal bei TV total zu Gast, um sein Buch zu promoten. Und Stefan Raab ist überhaupt nicht in der Lage, mit ihm ein Gespräch zu führen. Er kann nur fragen und wie reich wird man damit, dass man so ein Buch geschrieben hat. Und dann fragt er noch, warum er dann überhaupt so viel reißt. Und dann sagt Roger Wilmsen ja, dass man sich auf dem Sterbebett daran erinnern kann und nicht Raab sieht. Und das ist die richtige Antwort. Und dass wir jetzt eigentlich auch diese Opposition haben, inhalt oder nicht, führt ja dazu, dass man nur noch über die Quote nachdenkt. Und er spricht jetzt über das Fernsehen. Aber wir wissen ja, auch wenn hitfliche Richter das in Zweifel ziehen, dass Quote nichts anderes ist, als Mehrheiten zu bekommen bei einer Wahl. Und Wilmsen sagt Folgendes.
Das heißt, die Diskussion, die wir hier so freundlich führen, auf immer noch gehobenen Niveau, ist bei der digitalen Aufrechnung angefangen. Gehören Sie zu jenen, die uns Schwierigkeiten machen, Quote zu erwirtschaften, indem sie immer noch für Inhalte sind? Oder haben Sie es endlich begriffen, dass Inhalte komplett gleichgültig sind, gegenüber der Aufgabe, Quote zu erwirtschaften?
Gehören Sie, kann man jetzt übersetzen, zu den Leuten, die noch Inhalte wollen, die also damit den Wahlsieg gefährden? Oder haben Sie es endlich begriffen, dass es nur um den Sieg geht, also nur um die meisten Stimmen? Und die meisten Stimmen bekommen man, indem man keine Inhalte liefert. Und das finde ich eine sehr dramatische Entwicklung. Die ist nicht ganz neu, wie wir hier hören. Der Clip ist 20 Jahre alt. Aber dass das sehr stark zunimmt und dass das so sehr im Politischen vorhanden ist, das ist ja gerade an dieser völlig verrückt geführten Migrationsdebatte in Deutschland zu sehen. Denn wenn man über Inhalte sprechen würde, würde ja sofort diese Debatte anders verlaufen, weil man sich gar nicht auf sowas Gefühltes mehr beziehen könnte. Deswegen habe ich eine solch große Angst, wenn da die Show nur noch aufgeführt wird. Denn Friedrich Merz führt auch eine Show aus. Das ist eine andere, als die Kamala Harris aufführt. Und die von Kamala Harris ist mir natürlich auch viel sympathischer als die von Friedrich Merz. Aber beides sind eigentlich zwei Seiten einer Medaille.
Ich fand es auch ganz erstaunlich, dass man als zuständige Innenministerin im Bundestag das Begehren der CDU nach Abschaffung des Grundgesetzes usw. konnte, indem man sagt, wir können gerade der EU nicht erklären, dass wir in Deutschland eine Notlage haben, weil wir minus 20 Prozent Asylbewerber und wir hatten letztes Jahr keine Migrationsdiskussion. Und die Erstangrundstellen sind nur zu 50 Prozent gefüllt. Wir haben vor Gericht keine Chance.
Nun gibt es ja den Versuch, Inhalte zu machen im Fernsehen mitunter. ARD haben wir schon gesehen, für gescheitert erklärt. Aber das ist ja noch gar nichts gegen das, was das ZDF aufgeführt hat. Es gab eine Sendung, die heißt Wir sind fleißig, ihr seid Faulfragezeichen. Dort traten Boomer gegen die GenZ an. Hat irgendjemand dieses wunderbare Format gesehen? Nein, Glückwunsch. Aber dann werden wir das jetzt noch tun. Und zwar muss man sich vorstellen, diese Sendung dauert 45 Minuten. Es sind sechs Leute, die antreten. Es gibt noch einen Soziologen, der kommentiert. Und es gibt noch einen Spieler, die uns erklären, woher die einzelnen Kandidaten, die dabei sind, kommen. Und die uns noch mal generelles erklären über Immobilien in Deutschland, Ungleichheit, bla bla bla.
Sehr gut.
Wir hören mal rein.
Gegen die GenZ. Jahrgang 1995 bis 2010. Knapp 12 Millionen.
Okay, Boomer.
Es treten an Isabel Vivian, Tischlerin und Influencerin, die Zeitjournalistin und erfolgreiche Podcasterin Jasmin M. Barek und der YouTube-Star und Musiker Roman Lochmann.
Also von den Lochis, der sehr gut ist dabei. Wer steht auf der Boomer Seite?
Sportreporter Frank Buschmann, Schauspielerin Desiree Nick und die Unternehmerin Dagmar Wöhl.
Natürlich ist unsere Generation eine sehr fleißige Generation.
Also Opferbereitschaft, Durchhaltevermögen, Resilienz, das haben die Babyboomer immer wieder bewiesen.
Dagmar Wöhl, fügen wir noch hinzu, war für die CSU auch lange Zeit im Parlament. Wir erleben sie gleich wieder. Was fällt uns jetzt erstmal bei dieser Runde auf?
Also das Assombe ist ja perfekt. Heinz Buhle, ich sehe ihn da unten schon, Laun hat ja betont, dem Boomer fehlt bisher so ein Identitätsstiftendes, sie werden jetzt erstmalig beschrieben und zwar von außen. So, jetzt sehen sich die Boomer also selber im Fernsehen. Ihnen fehlt so ein Identifikationsmoment. Sie bekommen jetzt die drei Leute dahingesetzt als ihre Stellvertreter.
Ja und die jungen Leute bekommen, ja, also man muss es so sagen, von diesen sechs Leuten sind fünf reich. Die eine ist auch schon Influencerin, die ist vielleicht noch nicht ganz so reich wie Roman Lochmann, aber die anderen sind alle Millionäre. Dieser Sportmoderator ist für alle möglichen Sendungen, unter anderem auch Schlag den Rab und so überall gebucht. Das heißt, es sind alles sehr reiche Leute. Und dann hat man noch eine Journalistin, die aber auch auf allen Hochzeiten tanzt, Jasminem Barek. Das heißt, das sind alles sehr, sehr privilegierte Leute, noch nicht super reich, aber die meisten sehr reich. Das heißt, hier zeigt sich schon, dass sobald man über Generationen spricht, man eigentlich Unfug betreibt. Denn natürlich sind das jetzt zwei Generationen, aber deren Lebenswirklichkeiten haben mit den Leuten, die jetzt zum Beispiel hier im Saal sind und zwischen 50 und 60 sind, nichts zu tun und auch nichts zu tun mit den Leuten, die hier zwischen 20 und 30 sind. Das heißt, hier wird also etwas konstruiert, was überhaupt nichts abbildet von der Gesellschaft. Also da muss man ja fast noch diese 100 Sendung zu gut halten. Das sind ja tatsächlich noch in Handführungszeichen normale Leute gewesen. Hier versucht man irgendwas anderes.
Was wir nicht sagen durften, außer…
Ja, das sage ich auch gleich. Wer jetzt glaubt, wir verfolgen eine große Debatte, das ist gar nicht in diesem Format vorgesehen. Denn es ist so, dass man immer nur anderthalb Minuten von diesem Tischgespräch dieser sechs Leute, die da zu Abendessen mitbekommen, und dann kommt gleich wieder ein Schnitt und dann werden einzelne Protagonisten vorgestellt oder irgendwelche Infos präsentiert. Das heißt, es gibt nichts, was über 90 oder 120 Sekunden hinausgeht und an Debatte zu verfolgen. Keine Konfrontation können wir hier miterleben. Wir hören aber mal rein.
An einen Forderungskatalog an Unternehmen heran. Vielleicht für kurz ein Beispiel, wenn sie dann Meetings anberauben wollen und dann heißen, da habe ich keine Zeit. Also da bin ich früh, surfe ich erst mal zwei Stunden und mittags geht es auch noch einmal. Nach dem Surfen noch mal eineinhalb Stunden. Das verstehe ich dann nicht.
Dagmar Wöhrl ist inzwischen ja auch aus der Höhle der Löwen bekannt und ist Investorin und beklagt sich darüber, dass die GenZ laufend surfen geht. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wen meint sie? Naja, sie spricht ja nur mit Start-up-Leuten. Das werden Leute sein, die haben schon ein paar erfolgreiche Exits hingelegt und die brauchen aber dummerweise jetzt 100.000 Euro für das Next Investment von Dagmar Wöhrl. Und dann ist natürlich die Sache, ah, jetzt will die wieder zoomen. Ich gehe jetzt erstmal surfen. Das ist die Reaktion darauf, die ja absolut nachvollziehbar ist, die nichts aber zu bedeuten hat für die GenZ an sich.
Sie sollte sich wirklich Gedanken darüber machen, warum ihr immer gesagt, ey, ich muss da surfen.
Wie auch andere im Alter von Dagmar Wöhrl jetzt vielleicht in Rente gehen oder noch ein paar Arbeitstage vor sich haben, die sind aber gar nicht mit Leuten in irgendwelchen Meetings, die surfen gehen. Also hat nichts mit der Realität zu tun. Jetzt kommt auch noch, weil man denkt, sechs Leute und Einspiel-Clips und Erklärvideos reichen noch nicht. Wir brauchen noch einen Soziologen. Heinz Bude versucht das erst mal hier.
Er hat zehntelang zu Generationen geforscht, auch zu seiner eigenen.
Für Boomer ist es völlig klar, dass Erwerbsarbeit das Zentrum des Lebens ist. Also im Grunde man definiert sich über die Arbeit. Nicht so gut kann sie verstehen, wenn Leute sagen, ich muss gar nicht arbeiten oder gar der Meinung sind, dass es einen gesellschaftlichen Anspruch gäbe, finanziert zu werden, um sich selber zu finden. Weil sie sagen, selbstfindungsprozesse außerhalb der Arbeit, durch Weltreisen, wohin soll denn das führen?
Wie meint er denn da jetzt wieder? Also die Leute, die sich so selbst verwirklichen, ganz in der Arbeit und über das andere gar nicht nachdenken, das gilt ja auch wiederum für seine Professorenklasse oder so etwas. Aber das gilt ja auch nicht für alle normalen Arbeitnehmer. Also ich glaube nicht, dass zum Beispiel mein Vater behaupten würde, der Zahntechniker war, dass das für ihn eine permanente Selbstverwirklichung war, dass er sich gar nicht hätte denken können, was anderes zu machen. Er musste halt.
Aber es ist gut, wie sie ihn vorstellen, wie er jahrzehntelang geforscht hat.
Und er sitzt im Café und liest eine gedruckte Zeitung.
Er hat da mal was aufgeschnappt.
Dagmar Wöhrl, wie gesagt, CSU-Mitglied, hat Probleme und auch ihr Sohn hat es nicht leicht.
Ich kenne es bei uns aus dem Hotelleriebereich von meinem Sohn, der ja Hotels betreibt. Die finden niemanden mehr. Diese unstetigen Arbeitszeiten will keiner mehr machen.
Das ist ein ganz spannender Punkt, den wir gerade mal so nebenher wischen. Pflegeberufe, Krankenpfleger, wenn wir niemanden mehr finden, der diese Jobs macht.
Da muss man einfach sagen, ja, aber dann mach doch mal. Also Sportmoderator ist genauso wenig wie Podcasts eine gesellschaftlich notwendige Tätigkeit. Das ist quasi so ein Zür-Plus, das man sich gönnen kann. Aber wenn er das als so wichtig erachtet, stehen ja alle Türen offen für ihn.
Ja.
Das ist interessant und dass diese Rhenik da von Moral spricht. Also sei das der Ruf der Moral, der einen morgens zur Arbeit bringt.
Ich frag mich auch, dieser Gastro-Bereich wird ja immer so gescholten als so lebensunwirklich. In der Küche, im Service, wie auch immer. Wie kann das eigentlich sein? Also die Anforderung ist ja, gut aussehen vor dem Gast, das Haus in Ordnung halten. Du bist die ganze Zeit überdacht, es ist warm. Dir wird ja eigentlich ein Umfeld geboten, wie für den Gast. Es ist nicht Baustelle, es ist nicht der berühmte Dachdecker und so. Wie wenig die bezahlen, wenn noch die Schwelle Top Ten in Deutschland beim Einkommen wären schon 3700 Euro netto. Wo sortieren die denn die Leute ein? Also kriegen die die irgendwie 900 Euro im Monat oder so, dass die dann sagen, ne da bist du leider.
Und vielleicht noch ein Euro mehr.
Das ist wirklich grotesk.
Ja, natürlich, das sind die Summen, die da gezahlt werden.
Hat das denn jemand zurückgefragt in der Sendung, was sie für Gehaltsangebote machte?
Natürlich nicht. Passiert nicht. Work-Life-Balance, Desiree Nick.
Diese Vorstellung, dass gerade Arbeit der Work-Life-Balance widerspricht, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Desiree Nick ist Schauspielerin und Kapitän. Ja, für sie wird das Work-Life-Balance sein, weil es kein normaler Beruf ist.
Ich will mal einen Argument, eine Pointe vorausnehmen, obwohl ich sie eigentlich schon machen wollte. Wir haben nämlich tatsächlich verpasst. Ich habe im letzten Salon einen vorbereiteten Text nicht vorgestellt. Ja. Einfach nur, weil wir im Ablauf und so weiter. Und der amerikanische General, die Searching General oder so, also übersetzt ist es einfach nur der General-Chirurg. Also es ist so eine, dem Gesundheitsministerium untergliederte, mit 6.000 uniformierten Ärzten und so weiter. Der hat jetzt ein General Advisory rausgegeben. Da stehen immer mal so Problemlagen drin, die die öffentliche Gesundheit betreffen. Und jetzt aktuell ist es Elternsein. Allein Eltern zu sein ist eine gesundheitliche Gefährdungslage, nicht nur für dich individuell, sondern auch öffentlich. Das ist einfach ein grundsätzliches Problem. Eine Epidemie. Die Leute werden Eltern. So. Und das Einzelargument da drin war, erwachsene Leute, die gerade im Leben angekommen sind, haben Kinder und damit plötzlich einen neuen Problemhorizont, der sie völlig überwältigt. In was für eine Welt habe ich dieses Kind reingesetzt? Wie kriege ich das jetzt irgendwie hin und so? Wenn die hier irgendwie sagen, die wollen sich alle nur selbst verwirklichen, nein, die wollen einfach nur das Krasseste, das Größte irgendwie umschiffen und sie wissen nicht genau wie. Das sind die Sorgen dieser Generation und dann deren Eltern. Und dann wird uns im ZDF sowas gezeigt.
Wird noch übertroffen durch den Mann von Frau Wörl, nämlich Hans-Rudolf Wörl. Das ist so eine Kaufhausfamilie. Der Vater Wörl hat also in Nürnberg schon sehr früh, in den zwanziger Jahren einen Kaufhaus betrieben. Er war auch politisch engagiert, zum Beispiel als Fördermitglied in der NSDAP schon 1931 und dann ab 1933 auch in der SS.
Das ist doch hier beim Kühne, dem reichsten Mann Deutschlands.
Also ja, es war offenbar auch schon ein bisschen was da von Papa aus. Jedenfalls kann der mit Work-Life-Balance auch nicht so viel anfangen.
Also ich kenne dieses Wort eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe mein ganzes Leben Work-Life-Balance gehabt, weil ich mein ganzes Leben das gemacht habe, was mir Spaß macht, nämlich Arbeit. Warum brauchen die Menschen so viel Tätigkeit, die eigentlich für nichts ist? Was habe ich davon, wenn ich irgendwo hier durch den Wald laufe? Was habe ich davon, wenn ich mich mit irgendeinem schwierigen Hobby beschäftige? Ist doch viel geiler, irgendwas zu bewegen, wo man vorangeht.
Ja, bei 100.000 Euro pro Woche Einkommen macht man sich keine Gedanken um Work-Life-Balance. Wer hätte es gedacht?
Wenn man seine unternehmerische Tätigkeit in alle Richtungen ausstrecken kann, dann würde man auch nicht sagen, ich brauche dringend ein Hobby. Das ist ja völlig gar. Nur die, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen, haben es vielleicht ein bisschen anders und hätten doch so etwas wie Freizeit gerne. Das Konzept scheint ja gar nicht zu verstehen. Es gibt übrigens auch aus der ökonomischen Elite Leute, die was von Freizeit verstehen. Ich hörte den OMR Podcast. Dort war der Chef von Aldi Süd zu Gast, Ex-Chef Ulrich Wolters. Der erzählte von Karl Albrecht, dem Gründer, wie der so gearbeitet hat. Anfangs hat er natürlich auch das erst mal so aufbauen müssen. Aber dann, als es ein bisschen lief, sah sein Arbeitstag so aus.
Also das war jemand, dem man vertrauen konnte. War das auch ein super Stratege oder wahnsinnig arbeitsbereit?
Nein, nein, das ist ja das Interessante. Aldi, den kennenlernte, war es schon so, der kam ins Büro an vier Tagen von 9 bis 13 Uhr. An vier Tagen. Ich habe das bewusst gemacht. Nicht, weil das heute so modern ist, sondern am Dienstagmorgen ging er mit seiner Frau 18 Uhr Golf spielen.
Wirklich?
Ja, und damit das war nie da.
Ja, hat doch auch funktioniert, weil andere dann arbeiten. Aber auch das gibt es als Unternehmerbiografie.
Das größte Problem ist, dass wenn er Golf spielen will, haben seine Freunde keine Zeit.
Ja, deswegen nimmt er die Frau.
Wie kann das nur sein, dass sie keine Zeit haben?
Das irrsinnigste Argument kommt jetzt von Frank Buschmann. Man muss sich aus der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Wenn alle nur noch schönes Leben haben wollen, dann bleibt eins natürlich auf der Strecke, dass wir eine Solidargemeinschaft sind. Es gehört dazu, wenn ich möchte, dass es mir gut geht in einem Land wie Deutschland, dass ich nicht nur auf mich selbst schaue. Denn dann führe ich Ad absurdum, worauf unsere Gesellschaft ursprünglich basieren sollte.
Solidargemeinschaft, dieser Begriff dachte ich einen Moment, was ist denn das eigentlich? Solidargemeinschaft wird ja eigentlich verwendet, wenn man über Sozialversicherungen spricht. Also da haben wir eine Solidargemeinschaft, dass man nicht sagt, naja, die Kranken müssen da irgendwie sehen, wie sie es zahlen, sondern auch die Gesunden kommen für die Kranken auf und so weiter. Wir wissen aber in Deutschland, dass diese Beiträge, die dazu entrichten sind, gedeckelt sind. Das heißt, ein Frank-Busch-Mann verdient weit, weit darüber, nämlich über 90.000 Euro wird er im Jahr verdienen. Das heißt, für ihn werden diese Sozialbeiträge, die da fällig werden, gar nicht weiter steigen. Also er kann sich ab 90.000 Euro im Jahr aus dieser Solidargemeinschaft dann ganz gut entfernen. Sagen, trage ich nicht mehr, aber er fordert sich hier ein. Und Solidargemeinschaft meint ja bei ihm, dass manche Leute zu schlechten Bedingungen und wenig Geld arbeiten müssen, damit wir ein Land bleiben.
Was ist das hier für ein Sessel, in dem er sitzt? Vor einem Jahr war ich in so einer Wohnung, wo so ein Sessel stand. Und ich saß drauf und sagte, das ist ja so ein bequemer Sessel. Und dann habe ich gehört, was er kostet. 10.000 Euro.
Das ist die Solidargemeinschaft, hat das bezahlt.
Und er steht ungefähr zehn Meter von dieser Wand da hinten weg. Sein Wohnzimmer ist also größer als die Standardwohnung für Familien mit einem Kind.
Ja, wir leben in einer Solidargemeinschaft.
Das ist die Solidargemeinschaft.
Und die müssen jetzt sich mal zusammenreißen, dass es weiterhin so gut geht. Jetzt erleben wir auch noch die Tochter von Frank Buschmann. Sie leben in München und die Tochter verdient wohl auch schon ein bisschen eigenes Geld. Jedenfalls wird ein WG-Zimmer gesucht. Und jetzt sehen wir mal, wie die GenZ so ist, wie überheblich. Mit verrückten Vorstellungen im Kopf. Und das scheint wohl repräsentativ, so will uns das ZDF zumindest sagen, für alle zu sein.
Es ist nicht zehn von zehn, aber es ist auf jeden Fall, ich würde mal sagen, von der Lage her so eine sieben von zehn.
So, und du hast, du bist sowieso Schluss mit zehn von zehn. Das funktioniert nicht.
Nö, aber ich kann mir schon einen Standard irgendwie selber aussuchen und sage, da würde ich gerne möglichst nachher dran kommen.
Oder hier?
Ja, aber das sieht ja eh schon super aus.
Ja, weil es nicht zehn von zehn ist. Das ist ja schon so ein schönes Beispiel, womit du wieder jedes Klischee füttern kannst. Es besteht die Aussicht auf ein WG-Zimmer, was in München echt nicht leicht ist. Das ist ein Sechser im Lotto, dass du ein WG-Zimmer zu dem Preis, also deutlich unter Vierstellig, hier werden ja Hundehütten für 1000 Euro im Monat vermietet. Und ich registriere die Aussage, ja, von der Lage ist es, also maximal eine Sieben von Zehn. Da krieg ich Ausschlag. Ich glaube schon, dass wir, ob man das gut oder schlecht findet, mit dem Gedanken groß geworden sind, wenn wir fleißig sind, dann kann man sich auch was leisten. Und dieses sich etwas leisten können, war ganz am Ende der Kette und nicht direkt am Anfang.
Das kommt natürlich ins Familienbuch. Wenn man so schon mit seiner eigenen Tochter umgeht, um ihre Ansprüche auszutreiben, brauchen wir uns gesellschaftlich keine Vorstellung mehr zu machen.
Natürlich hat die Tochter auch gar nicht die normalen Probleme, die junge Leute haben. Vielleicht wird hier noch mal ihr so nahe gelegt. Du musst dich ja mal jetzt bescheiden. Während der Zeit als Studentin, dann hast du das auch mal erlebt, wie das so ist. Aber es besteht ja gar keine Notwendigkeit. Also Frank Puschmann ist ja einfach jemand, der dann irgendeine RTL-Talkshow moderiert, eine Sportsache oder bei Sky ist er auch. Und dann wird man dann gefragt, da ist jetzt noch mal der Raab, kriegt dann noch mal einer auf die Nuss oder so. Willst du das machen? Was willst du haben? Dann würde er irgendwas sagen, ja 40.000 oder so. Also das ist ja einfach eine Summe, die der dann anruft. Das hat ja nichts mit Fleiß zu tun. Also mein Gott, der hatte wahnsinniges Glück und dann kann er das kriegen, ja. Aber das ist ja nicht so lang, er war wohl der fleißigste Sportreporter.
Ja, also diese Raabsendung, das sind jetzt irgendwie 90 oder 100 Millionen über fünf Jahre. 30 Dinger pro Jahr oder so muss er dann machen. Das heißt, pro Sendung haben die einfach ein Budget für, also 800.000 Euro für 90 Minuten Fernsehen.
Ja, Raab wird wahrscheinlich sagen, muss ja noch alles versteuern. So was dann.
Da passt das mit der Wirklichkeit.
Wir hören mal in diese Diskussion rein. Also wir haben ja noch gar nichts von der Diskussion gehört und ich habe wirklich, als ich die Clips geschnitten habe, plötzlich gemerkt, ach, die Diskussion ist gar nicht da, aber die gibt es ja auch gar nicht. Aber einen Clip habe ich jetzt noch mal geschnitten, von dem bisschen Diskussion.
Aber da habe ich mal kurz gedacht, hä, da denkst du noch drüber nach wegen der Lage, wo sind wir? Ich habe in Köln damals, dann kommst du, und dann machst du diesen Fehler, du vergleichst. Weil meine Butze, die ich hatte, lasst mich nicht lügen, hat glaube ich 300 D-Mark damals gekostet im Studium.
Aber die Vorstellung von wie man lebt ist ja ein bisschen anders jetzt. Dieses Mietproblem, über Lebensprobleme, Inflation, Lebensmittelpreise, weil wenn du sagst 300 D-Mark, was hast du für ein Döner bezahlt Ende der 90er? 3 Euro, 2 Mark.
Aber es gibt ja wesentlich weniger junge Leute als die Baby-Boomer. Also es ist ja ein ganz knallharter Pillenknick gewesen. Da könnte man doch eigentlich auch sagen, wie gut ihr es habt. Denn die jungen Leute können sich ja auch sehr viel aussuchen. Ich meine, was möchtest du machen und sucht deinen Weg global. Ihr könnt ja euch vernetzen. Dann diese Erasmus-Studien, Austauschschüler. Sowas gab es auch bei mir gar nicht. Also jeder hat doch heute hinter sich dann ein Auslandsjahr. Praktika oder diese Reisen nach Vietnam, Backpack-Gap-Year. Das ist für mich alles wie aus dem Schlafenland.
Ja, gerade diese unbezahlten Praktika, die finde ich auch so toll.
Vielleicht war es noch leisten.
Ja, und so lebt diese Renek ein bisschen stattlich.
Ja, vielleicht, wir machen heute nur Rolle rückwärts immer, aber vielleicht hat ja Raab recht. Inhalte sind überbewertet, wir sollten das alles ausboxen. Aber mit demselben Protagonist.
Ja, und das ärgert mich ja an dieser, genau, das ärgert mich aber an dieser ZDF-Sendung so, dass man vorgibt, man würde Inhalte präsentieren wollen, man gibt vor, man würde jetzt eine Generationendebatte aufmachen. Man müsste eigentlich ansehen, dass es unsinnig ist überhaupt, über Generationen zu reden oder zumindest mal das in Zweifel ziehen. Und all das findet nicht statt. Stattdessen auch wieder nur verrückte Statements nach und nach. Jetzt hier nochmal Unternehmer Wörl.
Agmar Wörl und ihr Mann Hans Rudolf machen bis heute Dinge zu Ende und genießen, was sie verdient haben.
Früher haben die Leute gesagt, ich möchte ein Haus haben. Dafür haben die in der Woche 44 bis 50 Stunden gearbeitet, haben auf alles verzichtet, haben keinen Urlaub gemacht und haben 30 bis 40 Jahre an dem Haus anbezahlt. Nur keine Wehen mit den Einstrecken, man will sein Auto, man möchte seinen Urlaub, man möchte am Samstag nicht arbeiten. Okay, dann kann ich mir das nicht mehr leisten, was sich die Boomer-Generation leisten konnte.
Dass die Hauspreise sich irgendwie anders entwickelt haben, das hat er gar nicht mitbekommen. Es scheint nicht das Problem zu sein. Und ich habe es mir denn heute nochmal angesehen, in der Wirtschaftswoche gab es auch einiges zu Immobilien. Es ist ja so, wenn man jetzt ein Reihenhaus kaufen will, nicht hier direkt in Frankfurt, aber ein bisschen außerhalb, dann würde man wahrscheinlich so 500.000 Euro mindestens zahlen müssen. Und wenn man 100.000 Euro Eigenkapital hat, muss man 400.000 Kredit aufnehmen. Das bedeutet, beim jetzigen Zinssatz müsste man dann ca. 2000 Euro monatlich entrichten. Die Zinszettelung liegt dann bei 2%. Und dann läuft dieser Kredit über 30 Jahre. Wer kann 2000 Euro einfach noch rausgeben für den Abtrag? Die Top Ten. Aber nicht die, die er hier meint. Er redet ja hier von einfachen Arbeitern. Die haben sich halt einfach beschieden und dann konnten sie das realisieren. Nee, die müssten ja 100% ihres Gehalts weggeben oder 80%. Und dass das nicht funktionieren kann, müsste doch eigentlich sofort aufgefangen werden. Aber man lässt das alles mal hier so gewähren.
Ich finde das eh nervig, so Superreiche in einem ganz nüchternen Alltag zu sehen. Mit dieser Botschaft, die verzichten aber, also die wollen es gar nicht. Aber das haben wir ja bei diesem Sebastian gelesen. Es geht ja nicht darum, viel Geld zu haben, um es auszugeben, sondern um diese Sicherheit zu haben. Egal, was passiert, ich bin immer abgesichert. Weil dann muss ich es ja auch nicht ausgeben. Das nimmt dir ja genau diesen ganzen Drang, wenn du weißt, komme was wolle, ich komme immer raus. Ich kann mich immer rausziehen. Und das müsste doch eigentlich reinreflektiert werden. Stattdessen wird uns hier, und ich meine, der Reckwitz, wir haben ja schon gehört, in Julia Friedrichs Buch, er hat die Superreichen so als, ja gut, gibt es auch, aber spielt keine große Rolle. Sein nächstes Buch ist ja der Verzicht.
Ja, und ich schlage es für den Salon schon hiermit vor.
Ja, das kommt im Oktober, ja genau, also irgendwann mal gerne.
Ich möchte nichts von dir hören, dass die Empirie fehlt.
Nein, ich bin gespannt.
Wir nähern uns dem Finale in drei Schritten, nämlich man versucht ja jetzt, nachdem man nur Kraut und Rüben produziert hat, irgendwas Rundes daraus zu bekommen. Roman Lochmann.
Man ähnelt sich ja nur an die ganzen...
Schalte, das muss ich mal gerade zurück machen, das ist nämlich das Tollste überhaupt. Also wir haben noch einmal Dagmar Wöhrl. Dagmar Wöhrl, wie gesagt, CSU-Mitglied. Sagt jetzt, macht noch mal das Heidenreich-Argument.
Man ähnelt sich ja nur an die ganzen Bürgerrechtsbewegungen. Gerade mit Inklusion, gerade mit Gendergerechtigkeit, Anerkennung von Lebenspartnerschaften und Ehen von Homosexuellen. Wir sind ja damals auf die Straße gegangen. Wir haben das damals ja alles auch initiiert.
Elke Heidenreich, glaube ich das ja noch, aber die CSU hat genau all diese Errungenschaften torpediert. Bis zum letzten Moment, wenn es nicht mehr ging, haben sie gesagt, na gut, dann soll sie halt heiraten. Aber es war immer die CSU, die das blockiert hat. Und sie nimmt jetzt einfach das, und das ist das Problem, wenn man über Generationen redet, auch noch so als ihre Leistung mit dazu. Denn das waren ja irgendwelche Leute aus ihrer Generation, die sie wahrscheinlich eher verachtet hat.
Ja, das ist wie diese alten Leute, die noch mal ihren Enkeln die Welt zeigen wollen. Dann fahren sie nach Frankreich und die Opas erzählen so, hier war es so schön. Dann kommt die Frage, wann warst du denn hier? Muss so 42 gewesen sein.
Jetzt aber Finale Roman Lochmann und die anderen versuchen, so einen Schluss zu finden.
Was nehmen die Promis aus der Runde mit?
Ich glaube, dass dieser Generationskampf irgendwie auch so wichtig ist. Durch Reibungen steht ja auch eine Änderung. Und ohne Veränderung haben wir alle ein Problem auf dieser Welt. Ich fand hier, das war ein sehr respektvolles Auf-Augen-Höhe. Das würde ich mir irgendwie noch mal wünschen.
Und zwar von beiden Seiten.
Ja, von beiden Seiten.
Ich wünsche mir Boxen. Ja, abstimmen. Boxen oder Augenhöhe.
Wäre sinnvoller. Jetzt die Influencerin und Schreinerin.
Wir wünschen, dass wir nicht mehr gegeneinander gehen, dass wir nicht mehr in so großen Schlagzeilen denken und sprechen, sondern dass wir mit unserem Nachbarn im Endeffekt mal wieder ein Gespräch führen. Und ich habe euch sehr, sehr gespannt zugehört, jeden Einzelnen von euch.
Du hast viel dazugelernt heute.
Ich habe viel dazugelernt, Deverie.
So ist es. Ja, aber ich habe gerne dazugelernt. Ich glaube, was ganz, ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass wir uns am Ende des Tages die Hand geben, dass wir von den Erfahrungswerten, die ihr gemacht habt, lernen.
Und unsere Ideen mit einbringen dürfen.
Es war total spannend, mit euch heute Abend hier zu reden, zu diskutieren.
Danke für die Perspektiven.
Danke.
Prima.
Danke für die Perspektiven. Der Klassenfrieden ist hergestellt, alles ist perfekt. Wir sind reich. Hurra.
Das finde ich gut. Wenn ich da gesessen hätte und desirin Nick hätte mir unterstellt, ich hätte viel gelernt, hätte ich gesagt, es stimmt, Doreen.
Und auch noch aus dem Off ein paar schöne Worte zum Abschied.
Die Herausforderungen für unser Land sind riesig. Die Boomer haben reichlich Erfahrung und die GenZ neue Ideen. Die Aussichten könnten weitaus schlechter sein.
Was nehmen wir als Learning, wie man heute immer in diesen Business Podcasts mit. Wir sprechen nicht mehr über Narrative.
No.
Wir hoffen auf Chet-GPT, auf eine Herunterdimmung der Intensität und reden nie mehr über Generationen und fragen uns, wann wird das Fernsehen noch mal besser? Aber die Frage beantworten wir ja nicht. Die stellen wir nur in den Raum. Vielen Dank für den schönen Abend.
So ist es.